welcome to the dojin episode of trash
taste
so what you are about to witness is
probably going to be an
edited version or at least there's no
doujins that we can possibly show on
screen
um since a lot of the material we are
going to be covering is going to be
very explicit we're going to be talking
about it but you won't be able to see
any of it so if you'd like to check it
out
and also support the show then make sure
to go over to our patreon patreon.com
trash taste and uh where you'll get to
see all the panels on screen when we
talk about them exactly awesome
yeah if you want to jack off while
watching trash taste now you can't
but if not uh grab yourself a drink or
if you're just doing it anyway
you're welcome just welcome you can just
jack off to us i guess
no please don't please don't let's get
on with it
while you open the wine i will explain
what we're doing
this is going to be a wine episode
because we're going to need the alcohol
together we've been drinking a while on
trash taste because i feel like we've
been filming earlier
uh but yeah essentially uh i don't read
doujins as uh i've
expressed before you don't read i don't
read i don't really
stop i preferably i do not like my porn
to be
reading we could get into that uh so
instead we decided the boys have both
recommended me
three dojins each to read and then we
are going to
end on a very special one where i'm sure
people are going to be excited
we're going to talk about seven yeah
we're going to be talking about seven
doujins
six dojins and a mess metamorphosis
which we'll get into um so yeah and
there's a little special thing going on
where
i don't know whose is which so i've been
recommended since you have like no clue
at all
i think i've some of them i know some of
them i know i thought i thought some
were pretty obvious
very very obvious yeah damn you reading
two shots of vodka there god
damn okay some are very obvious some i
don't know
and throughout this i will be guessing
as well uh
who's who's dojin is which
recommendation
well mostly though most mostly though
this show is going to be
just watching me and god just enjoying
conor's reactions to our recommendations
i assume you both read each other's
recommendations yeah yeah yes
it's funny because we recommended three
dojinshi's each
and i remember giving the list giving
the list to joey and joey gave his list
and we were like damn we both
recommended jojo that were like 200
pages long
at least and we were just like connor
it's cool you don't need to read it or
just read like three chapters or
something
until you get like the general gist of
it all right yeah but then conor was
like
bet i'm like first of all
why do i even read doujins i don't even
know where you go like i was like
i'm totally confused there's lots of
sites and then i look for the sites you
know and i'm
it just gets to the point where i'm just
fighting for my [ __ ] life to get the
[ __ ] on full screen yeah
there's [ __ ] pop-ups every two
[ __ ] seconds i'm just
i'm just trying to do my homework and i
gotta i gotta worry about
[ __ ] hot single ladies in my area
it's terrible you'll get used to it how
long did it take you to read
everything i i was under the impression
right the dojins were like
30 40 pages no a lot of them are i mean
yeah how did you guys manage to find
all of them that were like 200 [ __ ]
because those are the best those are the
best ones yeah
and i remember you saying oh you know
just stop at one chapter
there was never any breaks in these
things so i couldn't just what do you
mean
they all had chapters not that i saw
when i was reading yeah i don't know
where i was reading them
when when it says at the end of the
chapter it says like
ending or like to
some of them literally have a whole page
that says chapter two
i did not see them but i read them all
she's surprised um so i'm gonna tell the
names
of these dojins which again
[Laughter]
[Music]
i'm going what else yeah suck you by
supporter uh-huh are you so you're
saying the japanese name and then the
translated name
is that what this is some of them have
like english translations of the
japanese name yeah
june
yeah very interesting title
yeah kyoshi okay torsato
and student yeah i mean i i i understand
that yeah yeah yeah
yeah so i mean i just went in order of
which one you gave me so i wrote okay
okay okay i read doria usagi to anthony
when should i guess who's i think it is
why did you guess it right again once
you get the right at
and i think because there was like a
lolly for like 10 seconds
this was the cover of the main girl this
is like she
she like emanates such shinobu energy
that connor is going to obviously get
the first thing i wrote was just from
the cover i think it's joey
this is literally going to be if it's
not a milf it's a loli
yeah what were your thoughts going into
just reading hentai because this is like
our
unofficial sequel to the hentai episode
i guess go check that out if you haven't
yet it is
it is exhausting reading porn well i'm
sure
it's like if you asked me to like okay
if you're if you're horny you want jack
off to something you can do it right a
10-minute video or whatever yeah
if you made me sit through like a
two-hour jv when i'm not horny i
couldn't imagine
like a worse experience in my life you
know because how long were you
collectively reading these doujins for
like three to four hours
what's because back to back well it's
because we thought right we were like i
i saw the list and i was like all of
these are like full on like
books yeah i read them all so i was like
oh okay so like you know a couple of
chapters each
max he just needs to get an idea of you
yeah
well there's only one of them i didn't
read fully was because there was like 20
800 500 pages right ridiculous yeah i
gave up on the first one but i mean
yeah it was just it was exhausting it is
really
like i i've sat through really bad
movies that i felt were less painful
like it is just difficult i like reading
dojins i i can see it you know
sometimes you see something like oh
that's hot and then i'm like
even if i wanted to jack off here yeah
how what am i supposed to do
do i just sit there and think about what
i'm looking at like that feels like i'm
like
i'm like de-evolving like at what point
do i just do like
morse code masturbating like where i'm
like oh dude that's so hot she's telling
she's gonna [ __ ] me and morphs
like i don't know to me i like the
movement i'm not seeing enough movement
you know
i'm not seeing enough movement my eyes
are not stimulated enough
um i don't know i was i was reading this
and i just like
every time i thought this was really hot
i'm like well what'd i do what would i
do
it's not continuing i have to continue
it in my hand
i don't know what to do i'm like what do
i do
what do i do what do i do it's not
moving it needs to move when does it
start moving
this is the exact reaction i wanted yeah
yeah even if i thought it was hot
you know i just some of them you know i
will admit some of them i thought were
quite attractive i thought they were
very well done yeah you know if they
were an anime form i'd not
i it's weird because like some of these
have had anime adaptations right i know
but like
to me like dojin the doujin version is
like always hotter
than the anime version i don't know what
it is about i mean the songs are very
more intense
yeah something i learned very quickly i
get like a way more intense feeling
from reading the doujins no no because
then than watching the anime out of no
no
no
to me like there's a it's a different
kind of art form right
because to me like like reading doujins
is like
like to me it's it's a really good way
to warm up right
right right because to me like who
really likes sitting through a 20-minute
hentai
you know that's i don't mind you know
i've got time you know
i mean most of the time i'm just like
whatever but for some reason in stories
and dozens i'm like
i'm listening come on yeah you're
reading joey
so to me reading dojons is just getting
the story you know getting getting the
context and getting being able to get
the story without having to like
just watch 20 minutes of just boring
build up and it's so much
hotter when you understand the context
i like speed run the story most of the
time anyway like yeah it's if it's like
this you know you know what they're
doing it's
all right
i've got enough understanding of the
plot that i can go now yeah right i can
do it i can enjoy so did you
like does did you like input any of the
stories of anyone yeah no i did i
actually like because obviously when
you're reading it's really hard to
not ignore the story you can't double
tap it's really really frustrating yeah
you couldn't get you can
i skip like this is a this is a facial
floor of books you can't skip any of the
stories
the cut scenes you can't just go
straight to the gameplay
as much as i tried all right so
let's start with the first one then
it was quite quite hot but then it was
also really weird
really really weird so i i mean like so
so there's this
girl who's a ghost but she's then not a
ghost i think she's taking medicine
to go invisible and then she's like
sucking him off in the class
and no one can see him suck no one but
she's invisible but he's not so why is
his dick invisible this is gonna sound
really strange
this was a very confusing plot oh yeah
so if you care about reading the
dojins we're gonna be spoiling it i
guess if you care about the plots
spoil the world this was like this was
like for every like in this one at least
for every like one moment that i was
like oh that's hot it would literally do
10 other things so i'm like what the
[ __ ] is this
yeah honestly i i i cuz after you've
read the
everything because i only like i thought
you're just going to read a few chapters
i read a few chapters of joey and then
when you said you read everything i went
back to just completely finish
everything as well right i feel like
there's just a complete 180 at the end
as well where it starts going into this
other backstory i'm like no no yeah yeah
i don't know
that that author tends to do that with
everything he writes there was just like
moments in there where i had to write
down
it was like this [ __ ] is mad in cell
these
isn't that most doji's that's most
oranges because there was a
where like oh these girls are wearing
skirts they're such [ __ ] and i'm like
all right
all right okay jesus i know what i'm
getting myself into
uh i mean look i mean look at the main
character he's just he's like
okay i guess before he gets into it joey
do you want to explain why you should
why did you use this why
did you choose this one okay so
literally
i'll admit this was the part where i was
like [ __ ] i don't know what to do for
the third one
okay uh but but uh i like everything
uh by akatsuki mito who's like this
artist so honestly any one of his could
have been on this list right
but i figured like probably the least
weird one for connor
would be this one the least weird no at
least
i feel like this is not the least
there's a few other i mean
it's not that bad at least weird out of
his works
oh okay yeah yeah i mean like the other
two are ones that i actually really
enjoy
yeah that like immediately came off the
top of my head you know the one thing
that i i wish they would just chill out
with on dojins is just how fast [ __ ]
escalates
it goes from like ooh to like gangbang
in the showers within like four pages at
times
and i'm like hold on hold on hold on
there's no time to [ __ ] around
let this boy chill her out a little bit
let him play some video games be like
[ __ ] i just [ __ ] you know like damn
i don't know why you're suggesting that
because you're probably going to skip
over it yeah i know i know but it's it's
just like oh god okay i'm like i should
have picked oh god we're [ __ ] i'll
just
give me a warning i actually had like
out of everyone i had the most trouble
following
this story this was really confusing i
thought it was like a really
simple story and then like the last
chapter here so i'm just like what is
going on right now
because i'm i'm [ __ ] stupid can you
explain the basic supremacist of the
story
from what i said it's from what i
understand
this guy this was i had okay so again
you're not found i want to spoil the
thing because you find out more earlier
on but we'll start from the start you
just kind of find this guy
kind of like a normal cell kind of i
mean something like that
you know wants to get revenge on all the
women around him and then a girl
transfers into the school
who then immediately just starts he's a
ghost
yeah starts [ __ ] him but then so show
up just so only
he can see her but no one else can see
her so
she gives him glasses or something that
makes
yeah she she gives him some glasses that
make all the clothes
yeah that make all the clothes see
through so he's just looking at all
these naked girls while while being
sucked off by this invisible girl even
though no girl can see yeah
so this girl immediately starts sucking
him off right right away and then
i hate it when they do this when they
refer to the the characters when they
refer to themselves in the third person
to me i'm like stop that what is that is
that is that what they did yeah they did
that in the
only in the first scene i was like oh
god please don't make this a constant
thing
she's like calling herself her name
which is charlotte i think yeah oh yeah
yeah yeah she's like charlotte is happy
and i'm like yeah yeah she calls herself
third person um
admittedly it's been a while since i
read this yeah
i was hoping you could bring more
context into it okay but but i remember
the reason why i picked this one is
because
it literally has every tag i guess
that's what i enjoy about it like you
get
the best of i was about to say both
worlds everywhere everywhere
every multiverse there's a lot and so he
[ __ ] he [ __ ] the the ghost
[ __ ] and apparently no one else can
see even though he's like clearly nuts
yeah
yeah this guy is literally nutting he's
like are you telling me
and she's like are you okay yeah like as
if no one would notice that you're you
know come on yeah
to be honest that sounds [ __ ]
hilarious it's hard to believe that this
is attractive because yeah there's
there's no way i could be like oh that
that's hot that could be me like no
it could never ever be me and i not that
i would ever want to go sucking i don't
want casper sucking me off
yeah but you know it's kind of you know
what i mean
basically like the first the first
chapter just kind of reminded me of like
some like some porn spin off of bunny
girl's empire right
yeah you know you know where he's in the
library and you see my sees my for the
first time and no one else to see him
this is basically just that you know
this is that if it was rating yeah yeah
yeah exactly i know i've watched hentai
so i know this [ __ ] exists but there was
one
piece of dialogue as well where like the
bully girls who are like attractive or
whatever all the gals all right
oh yeah yeah you know they ask him for
money
and that's so inexcusable that in return
he's gonna [ __ ] them
that's how he's gonna get back at that
yeah and i'm like what the [ __ ] is this
watching like what about it's in so long
i don't know i know
i was like she literally asked you for a
tenno what do you mean
i don't think it's that bad how dare you
uh
yeah okay now he becomes horny casper
the ghost
he goes that's why he goes invisible i i
was not following the story at all so
then what happens is
is that uh he the girl this
charlotte ghost girl yeah then is like
well don't worry homie i got you and
starts like drugging
the other people in the class that make
them horny oh yeah yeah yeah and then
she introduces like new power-ups this
is like the fastest
that's what i'm saying man like it's
every time and then he's like hold up
but now you can drug them
and then i'll give you invisibility
drugs and it's like but you only got 30
minutes and then he starts [ __ ] like
the whole school and then and then they
find out and then they don't care
and then they carry on [ __ ] and then
this just goes insanity and literally
the whole school is being [ __ ] by this
guy within like i'm literally 10 minutes
into the story
and this is what's going on i can't i
can't think like what is happening
which girl is which i don't know which
they all have the same hairstyle wait a
minute is this girl robin wait which
one's the which one
no what is happening it was at this
point where like you know you know when
there's like so many girls that all of
them just start blending in together
yeah yeah and you're just like i don't
even know who you're [ __ ] anymore you
know
right like you know and then where the
[ __ ] did this willy wonka candy come
from where everyone's everyone's just
[ __ ] horny now where does it come
from
where's the backstory to that
and then later on we find out that uh
the main girl who he won the [ __ ] the
whole time
yeah uh was some poor homeless girl that
he was speaking to in the start oh the
student council girl yeah that he got
made fun of for talking to
and then the girl wishes that they never
met or you know he wishes that he never
and then his dog his doll comes to life
and that's the one he's [ __ ]
then she brings the drugs what is going
on that's that's what confused me it was
that chapter where the door starts
talking and i'm just like have i just
skipped over a chapter because it just
this is literally like lord of the rings
when you miss like one page you're like
hold up did i just miss the whole
i don't miss the whole story the whole
point of this i didn't go back 20 pages
it feels like i just got a shyamalan
twist without having a shaman movie yeah
like i just i think every page is like
i can't keep up with it i'm just like
what is going on but like there'll be
like two moments i'm like that's hot
but then what is going on okay okay what
i didn't understand was okay so
was the main girl just was she wearing a
wig the entire time was that the twist
oh
like he shows up at this house and he's
just like
what's the girl's name again like
charlotte he's just charlotte
and it's it's it's a girl with black
hair and then charlotte [ __ ] runs
away
and she starts putting her on a wig
right yeah yeah i mean
am i following this correctly wait what
i don't know this is this was like the
second to last chapter
right i thought it was just like you
know what i i honestly got very confused
i'm not gonna lie there's multiple times
i reread this ending like four times and
i still didn't understand what was
happening
and then like they just pull like you
know he he literally
it's just the the sheer like
how it just changes like completely it
literally ends on like a gangbang and
then the next panel it's like
you can just you could hear the anahana
music playing but really
there's a sad backstory as to why he's
[ __ ] here
oh get the [ __ ] out of here what is this
i don't give a [ __ ]
no i'm not gonna lie i i chose this one
because i knew
you guys would react like this because
it's so ridiculous that i just love it
like you know that shonen trope where
like the villain gets defeated and then
after the villain's defeated you finally
see his backstory
that's like that that doesn't belong in
a hentai you know
you can't just you can't just [ __ ] a
girl and then just show her backstory
after she gets [ __ ] okay
like i need this context before the
[ __ ] happens
it's like it's like putting a backstory
in the middle of a fight right he's just
like why now why now
you couldn't wait until afterwards i'm
not gonna lie some of these are blend no
it's blending into my head this is the
one and it just ends how does this one
end
it ends with this random [ __ ] side
story of someone
with the marriage like what is happening
and like i don't i didn't
recognize any of these characters
characters look the same it wasn't even
the main [ __ ] character
but they just [ __ ] they just [ __ ] for
some reason even though he just cheated
right before he's like wedding day or
something
he like cheats right before his wedding
day like the whole story is like they're
a fan club of him
i think yeah they're a fan club of the
ghost that [ __ ]
like the the main protagonist the incel
guy
they make a fan club of him in the side
story but i don't recognize any of these
characters
no no and then two of them are getting
married
and it's not it's not even the main girl
it's a different girl
and then he cheats on her right before
the day of and then there's a whole
scene of does anyone object to the
marriage
and they were like i do
it's like this [ __ ] is insanity
there's so much [ __ ] happening that i'm
like what do i even begin to critique
because there's just way too much [ __ ]
going on it's like someone he's he
literally pulled up every genre and he
was like a bet
yeah like i'm gonna get that's exactly
what he did it's like is there a genre
where it's like
you know uh shout out at the wedding no
that could be a tag yeah it probably is
[Laughter]
because he's [ __ ] so many girls now
that i can't even count how many girls
he's [ __ ] like
okay to me you know i like i said on the
hentai episode you know there has to be
some kind of story in there and there
was oh now you care about story huh
and hentai i do yeah i need a little bit
of story which is why
this is the only time some of them it
might shock you that i enjoy later
like this one was just like what the
[ __ ] is happening it's a dumbass story
[ __ ] keeps getting weirder and weirder
no not in a funny way like yeah one
hentai where people start shooting each
other and there's dubstep
there's no dubstep to go dubstep would
have gone great with some of these
scenes oh yeah yeah
i wish there was a built-in like dubstep
you could have just gone on to youtube
honestly this is the kind of yeah it's
literally the kind of doji where i put
on skrillex in the background and it'll
be well paced like yeah
honestly like reading this i i feel like
my boner got whiplash
yeah with the amount of [ __ ] that was
happening
you're just like gotta work out after
that
every time you you're like i'm into this
it's like no no no no no okay
it's like you start getting into it nope
new tag okay well i guess i'll just nope
okay new tag okay
and i'm just like okay what is the theme
to this what was
what was the author what was the vision
what was the author trying to say
this is literally what tags you want yes
this is what this is it's terrible it's
[ __ ] terrible you know to me it
needed like
it needed okay this is going to sound so
[ __ ] pretentious it needs it it needs
something to connect all the dots
right no i honestly i'm gonna agree with
you oh my [ __ ] god are we agreeing on
something connor
my [ __ ] god this fellow trash tastes
first this felt like just
ten dojins that have been like let's
just [ __ ] ram them into one
we got these sexy girls that i don't
want to redraw or in different ways like
you know you know what this felt like
this felt like it was like if the mcu
had one recurring character in every
movie
right but then it was just like it was
it was one continuous narrative
but it's because every movie genre is so
[ __ ] different
you just don't know what the [ __ ]
going on you can't follow anything
it's like playing all the mcu movies at
once
i i gave this one uh uh i originally
wrote down seven but that can't be right
i'll give it like a five really oh we're
doing scores i would have given it
personally i gave it a five is this one
got an anime advertisement like a hentai
adaptation
i think so i don't think so i don't
think anything biographies
got in an anime but i mean
i guess i guess before we move on though
what did you think of the art
it's fine it's pretty good the art's
pretty intense i mean i feel like
that's what i like a lot more fluids
going on in uh the dojins and the anime
adaptations
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah uh yeah
they're gonna be
i was like that's pretty damn good i
mean i can't figure out that you know
yeah
was i don't think there good any of
these dojins where the art put me off
except um
i liked all of them actually i'd say all
of them had their merits yeah
so like in his other work she said this
one was one of the least
weird ones right what's what's so weird
about his other works well what happens
in his other works if you can't remember
and uh ashley can you put on the air
conditioning right now because i'm
getting a bit heated
literally and fizz mentally and
physically right now so there's another
one
when i was like thinking of what the
last one is right i was like all right
let me go through my favorite artist and
see if there's one i can remember
and then i got to his works and one of
them i wanted to recommend was one
called lingua franca
okay which is also done by him and again
this is a while since i've read this one
but
oversimplified premise is yeah a guy and
a girl
are flying a plane across an island and
they crash land onto said island
and that island has this secret
civilization of all these like amazonist
girls
who live there this is a future armor
episode and the guy
gets kidnapped by that civilization
because
he's the first male that they've seen in
like over a hundred
literally this is like snooze yeah this
is literally the future armor episode
literally that's why snooze oh my god
but then there's like but then you find
out there's like
this like alien species that has been
controlling that civilization
that's the futurama literally yeah
there's a robot controlling them i do
not remember that
blender makes outwards i can't believe
futuristic literally
that's literally a future armor i can't
believe futurama ripped them off like
that
cease and desist incoming i mean if you
had to give this a rating what would you
give it then
um i'd say like six or seven really yeah
it's good but it's not my favorite of
yours i i think the best part of this
was the art yeah
the ending and the fact that it ended
honestly
the ending just made me confused and i
don't like it when they put a one shot
with totally different characters
there's like 10 pages that just confuses
me i'm like wait should i be
what's going on the bonus question when
they do that yeah
yeah well that's like the bonus content
you get from buying the full book
right rather than just reading in
magazines yeah i'll
give it i'll give it five it was like
that's awesome
huh that's a pass i i've seen like a lot
of hints i like this where just like all
right
let's just get into the [ __ ] as fast
as possible what is the premise all
right premise done how many girls can
this [ __ ]
in one single sitting yes yeah and that
was just the center i mean it was it was
good it was good you know
i'll admit even though i recommended it
it's nothing special okay i just really
like the
you're just grossed me off no i just
really like the artist okay
and how [ __ ] ridiculous and like
he just like his passion for just being
like
finna put every tag that i can it's a
wonderful show it's like i respect it i
respect it
all right what's the next um succubus
supporter
oh yes yes yes which one do you think
this is
whoever chose this new me well i'd say
right uh
i think i have this as joey here okay
it's mine oh okay okay okay this one
this one could have gone either way
yeah you know what's funny is that this
is one of
this is one of three that i've read
before yeah yeah i was gonna put it in
until gantt sent me his list dude it's a
classic
it's like one of the top rated it's one
of i think it's one of the most famous
dojinshi's like long formed agencies
yeah
of all time yeah and for good i see one
and for good [ __ ] reason
like it's art is great story's great all
this great story is great and
just blow jobs
blow your [ __ ] minds so essentially
how this story starts is there's just a
guy who doesn't have a job
chilling on a bench and then succubus
come up to him uh kind of like a
you know like a hot singles in your area
yeah yeah but i already
come up to him they're like hey uh do
you want a job helping us suck your
buses
and he's like oh i don't know what that
is but okay sure
so to give a bit more context so this
world has like
has like success have integrated into
the human society
so like they're not this mythical
creature anymore
so like a lot of most of the population
of the world
has some succubus blood in it right
that's right and the science is
that the more succubus blood that's in a
guy
the less tasty their
semen is fluids their fluids are come on
youtube
okay okay i'm sorry i'm sorry wake up
gamers because this video is sponsored
by gamer sops
as you all know we've officially
partnered with gamerself
why the powder tastes great it's cheaper
and healthier than other energy drinks
and mixes
perfectly gone but in all honesty i'm
just here for the amazing selection of
waifu cups
look at all these beautiful waifus
that's how you know how gamer we are
my microphone just came off as i was
saying all of the waifu cups you see
here are limited edition so you should
get them quickly if you
think you're a true gamer girl these
shirts and cups always sell out so if
you want your chance to get your waifu
you have to move
fast what are you gamers waiting for go
and get your waifu cups and support the
show by using coupon code trash
taste buy lots of stuff so we can get
our gamer subs
flavor and comment what you think it
should be called i am being held at
gunpoint but it's because i'm a gamer
and i play games
back to the show gamers and of course
our
main guy here is one of like
90 like one of the 0.1 percent of the
population
less of left that is just your human
that is just pure human blood
right pure no succubus blood in this
family tree
and of course the job he is given is
to basically just like provide an all
you can eat buffet
that's that's the best way i can provide
one man
one man versus the world
i i mean i like this one it was very
good how can you not like
this is one of the like least offensive
ones like what guy wouldn't want this
yeah just literally just you just a
piece of meat you know just yeah yeah
i'm just
one one one thing that like because this
artist i feel
is probably like the best artist when it
comes to drawing blow job scenes i mean
this doge this dojinshi in general is
just 90 [ __ ] right
i think there's like one sex scene in it
and it lasts like two three pages or
something right
it's it's mostly mostly blurry yeah yeah
yeah
so clearly we know what this artist
likes
this is like it's like literally the
[ __ ] you wish you were giving like
like if i could give this manga a
summary it's pretty much there
uh i mean yeah i mean what is not to
like about this the
like i said like the god tier art
positions are fantastic yeah
yeah fantastic okay here's the question
do you think this would translate
well into a hentai yeah dude if [ __ ]
pink pineapple made this
hell yeah i'm there wait did this not
get a hentai
no no i stayed at home succubus got one
yeah yeah yeah
the other one the other one got it i
don't know like what what i think
wouldn't translate well is that
the [ __ ] [ __ ] scenes here are so
intense i couldn't see it translating
well
into hentai yeah might be able to be
done i don't know
maybe science will advance and we'll get
good technology to be honest
like it'll be it'd be like a 20 minute
bj scene
so yeah they have this story where okay
so they just start [ __ ] him and then
apparently his you know his pp is so
good that they're like we made a website
about your dick oh yeah they made me go
viral didn't they they made him go viral
like oh by the way we've we've put your
dick online don't worry by the way we
haven't show your face yeah
yeah yeah of course uh but your dick's
famous now to all the other succubus in
the world
and then like oh okay there's more
psyche in this
like it's an idle handshake thing where
you can come and instead of handshaking
an idol yeah
suck the dick yeah yeah so so so these
succubus they're like hundreds of
succubus show up to this
handshaking event where they're shaking
events yeah yeah where they get where
they pay them
an amount of money to get like five
minutes
to uh milk the cow right
that's that's the best way to describe
it right yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah pretty
much um that was probably my favorite
chapter
i'm just like that was one [ __ ]
intense chapter yeah
just just i because normally i'm like
i'm not into like the whole harem angle
of it
but it was so like the concept was so
overdone and the art was so great and
it was just some of the scenes were so
[ __ ] intense that i'm just like
yeah that's hot all right that sounds
it's very good very very good stuff
getting flashbacks this this is this is
one where it's like
if i am suffering to like you know pick
one
first for the job yeah this is the
conflict this is the one that i always
go back to yeah
i mean the reason i picked this one is
because like out of out of
every dojinshi if i were to pick one
where i'm introducing someone to
like the world of dojinshi and what it's
like then this one's just like
this one's just like an all-rounder in
every category right
this don't miss it don't miss
this is the [ __ ] naruto of hentai
okay it's it's the gateway drug okay
i mean yeah because like the content
like the tags are so inoffensive
where it's like it's not too weird where
it's like oh i'm not really into that
like everyone's into [ __ ] bj's
like who doesn't love blow jobs right
who wouldn't want
three succubuses i mean that's i mean
you know
this is this is the equivalent this is
such a god i wish that would me dogan
and it's okay right because it's
succubuses right so if you're not too
early that's like great they like that
that's what they want they want
yeah no disappointment oh god
yeah i mean what i liked is that they
gave context to you know you know
normally like a hentai protagonist can
orgasm like an ungodly amount of times
yeah i like the fact that they gave it a
reason
for him to be able to orgasm that amount
of time which is just like
like if you feed on the pheromones or
something they have no yeah they have
pheromones and if you like
like feed on their spit or something
yeah yeah yeah it's always the saliva
yeah if you swap like
if you swap body fluids then it's just
like like this
[ __ ] mega aphrodisiac yeah and the
semen is like an aphrodisiac for the
succulent right that's like a two for
a never-ending cycle oh god the perfect
system doesn't exist
in this story after they they have this
whole handshaking event
uh they put his face online anyway yeah
they're like come
come guys look how amazing this guy is
yeah and then suddenly
a [ __ ] sudden dairy lolly shows up
and i'm like what's all this
are you getting in the
because i didn't know which which one of
you did those right yeah that was what
tilted it in the head
i was like i was like
oh yeah this [ __ ] yeah i remember first
reading that
and then she's like hello i am the
mother yeah and then i was like i was
like
literally the headset meme of like
taking the headset
you had it you had it why did you
introduce a [ __ ] lolly
it was so good so because what's so
funny is that she's technically
a lolly milf right
it's the both worlds everybody wins
literally i wasn't even wearing a
headset but i metaphorically pulled one
out
for that meme i'm like [ __ ] this [ __ ]
just did the movement [ __ ]
it was so bad god it was it was so
perfect you know i was enjoying life it
was great you know and then this
happened
it ruined it for me it was great there's
no pleasing even
even with the most inoffensive version
there's no policing
i just didn't like and she got a whole
own section i was like no one else got
their own section
why do you get your own section they do
later on but at this point no one else
had their own section at this point
why does the [ __ ] lolly who just
showed up looking like a [ __ ] bratz
doll
get to have a whole [ __ ] 20 pages
what's this
i don't want this i'm like [ __ ]
speedrunning this [ __ ] trying to get it
over with
like when is anything else gonna happen
and then luckily luckily it saved itself
guns the next the next chapter
and then suddenly they introduced that
like oh by the way there's a union for
sucky basses
because of course there and they have a
headquarters
yeah yeah he gets shipped off to like
the [ __ ] u.n or something right
the [ __ ] u.n of succubus is shipped
off and then they're like by the way
succubuses have been stopping wars for
generations because we [ __ ] people into
submission
so no wars because everyone is happy
because we [ __ ] them and it's like oh
okay i mean i guess that
i guess it makes sense of course god i
gotta introduce some world building
somewhere yeah
i have wars if you're [ __ ] right jeez
and then uh yeah i really like that
woman she was great she was very
attractive i very much like that just it
looks like a milk
oh yeah she does i thought she was she
was right up my alley i was like this is
great
you do look like an office lady tag yeah
yeah because she was also
you know she was also like oh no i don't
want it don't want it but then she did
want it
but it was obvious the whole time yeah
yeah [ __ ] yeah of course yeah of course
we're an adult
yeah yeah it wouldn't have been such a
shamal twist where they introduced
someone she's like i don't want it he's
like understandable
i want to watch a porno where the
plumber comes and just fixes something
and then just leaves and then she just
masturbates
i want that that's very available my
expectations you know give me something
throw me a curveball you know you know
maybe we're deconstructing porno now
yeah exactly
do it uh yeah but i mean i think i wrote
down i said this would have been a 10
out of 10
if they didn't have the [ __ ] lollies
the lolly intrusion as i called it
intrusion oh my god yeah i mean i
i wrote the art as god tier like pretty
much everything was god too i'm really
[ __ ] around with a out of 10 i mean
yeah it's
it was probably my favorite out of all
of these in terms of
could i not do it yeah yeah definitely
the that that does not surprise you this
might be
just pictures i think i could manage i
think yeah but if i scroll really the
first thing i did when i looked at like
the list with gotten mine is like
this is going to be common this is going
to be my taste
i'm like this man likes vanilla this is
the most vanilla i mean it's it's
it's not so much vanilla as so much as
so it's just it's just universally
inoffensive that this is god teardojin
oh yeah it's it's one of the best oceans
ever made some of the best art ever made
um hasn't yet gotten a hentai adaptation
which i'm just like
how is this not good in hentai
adaptation i would appreciate an
adaptation to this
maybe all the studios are scared
and a queen bee cracking dude if queen
bee adapts this i would cry
so hard to take a shot at this just
comes from behind
because because what sucks about queen
bee is that when you it's
like every queen bee dogen that seems to
get adapters it adapted it's like
a dogen i respect like close to this
level right yeah it's it's a godzillion
that gets passed around you're like
brilliant this looks [ __ ] fantastic i
mean i feel like when i when
i see people in the comments or these
websites we're like oh god it's queen
bee i'm just like i don't even know who
this this dojian is
i could have never been disappointed
what is this and frankly
i don't even know who you are i
literally don't even know who you are so
like it's not a problem but some of them
i still manage you know queen bee
does a good enough job sometimes you get
enough jobs right to get the job done
you know yeah the the task can be
complete
uh but yeah i know i mean this is just
great so i highly recommend if you
haven't read dirgens
you know what i would prefer queen bee
did actually instead of what they do now
i would prefer that if queen bee
animated their dojins or animated their
hentai the same way
that um animated doujins are made no
kind of like uh what was that uh house
uh the yuck is a husband one i got
animated oh where the hell's husband
where wherever the house husband
yeah you know what i i do for slide
shows yeah not slideshows
just like an animated comic i would
actually prefer that style
over where they just copy each frame
whether they just copy each phrase
because true because to me like a motion
comic would give way more
of like an impact than what whatever the
[ __ ] queen bee do yeah like please queen
bee please
i i i could i can handle that just just
give me a motion call me queen
how much how much how much you need like
20 bucks
yes [ __ ] you know yeah i mean like
uh i wrote eight out of ten because of
lolly lollipop i would give it a nine
it would have been a ten out of ten if
there was no laws honestly i'm not
joking that's serious
would you would you be interested in
these other works then
are they is this good yeah this artist
is really good most of his work is very
[ __ ] oriented
like he's just he's just the [ __ ]
team i mean i always think
you know [ __ ] is like the best
visually part like the visually like
sexual thing blow job is probably the
most attractive looking i think
when done right yeah yeah it's like a
it's like a macaroon
that's a little [ __ ] sweet yeah you
know what i'm going with this
you always see those sweets right you're
like the french
because you look at a macaroon right
you're like that looks amazing that's
[ __ ] amazing i really really want
that
and they never ever ever taste as good
as they look
and that's how i feel about bloating
really yeah really yeah
why because i can feel the soul
bro they make it look like [ __ ]
wrestlemania smackdown whirlwind on the
dick
it's not like that in real life oh [ __ ]
you know
it's not what it's like that's not what
it is that's what it looks like in the
entire race it's very aggressive it's
very aggressive
but i mean actually a lot of work
sometimes you know sometimes it's
awkward you just realize that you're
just standing there and you're just like
oh [ __ ] it's
awkward isn't it so much work you know i
mean it's just like
sometimes sometimes like what's so great
about [ __ ] is that there's literally
no pressure to do anything
you know right because you know
sometimes
sometimes i get that moment where like i
get distracted for one second and i get
taken out of it i'm like [ __ ]
[ __ ] i have to do my taxes [ __ ] now no
no
no now i got to pretend like i'm still
i'm still there i'm still in the zone
oh yeah ah
[ __ ] i really gotta follow his taxis
though [ __ ] i really forgot about that
oh god i can't do it now can i it's
gonna be really awkward if i if i go and
do those now
babe can i hear my laptop real quick
i'm just gonna file these taxes
but yeah that's good it's good it's good
all right all right next one uh it was
the
i already know who this one was this is
[ __ ] degenerate all right which one
jesus oh you said so bad live
consultation
after 10 years okay be me guys be me
you sit there right i don't i only know
right i don't know one thing
right i know the word oromo right
and i know i know it means incest i know
gaunt likes incest for some reason
guys as i said before oremo isn't an
incest
anime
this uh this is very much an inspiration
i have not
ex i have not watched aurora i open this
thing don't worry you don't have to
it's literally i feel like i understand
the story of the
the anime through this yeah which is
very concerning
because [ __ ] this is whatever you're
thinking about is probably what happened
in oremo
there is so many things in this anime
that made me like push my
desk chair back a little bit and go like
all right yeah because this one i saw on
the list i was like oh i've never heard
of this one i'll i'll check it out
[ __ ] open up it's just
[ __ ] up oh no no my one just because i
read mine in japanese yeah so my one
just said
england and i was like oh okay this one
you know sounds interesting
first page is literally just like kieran
with massive teeth i'm like
all right okay i knew this one you did
this your [ __ ] troll didn't
no no no no you [ __ ] dick
don't tell me you're like this is to me
probably the hottest like series dojin
i've ever read what
why because like i purposely avoided
parodies okay i this i i thought we i
thought we
you know because if that was the case i
would have recommended like three of my
favorites are all parodies yeah so this
was this is like the only
parody like parody dojian that is on the
list but like
i didn't know if we were avoiding
parodies or not yeah but i just wanted
to talk about this in the matter what
parody episode in future
and it's like because like most parody
most parody dozens they last for like
one chapter they asked like 20 pages
yeah it's like 10 30 pages yeah this
this one last this one's on an entire
[ __ ] story
i felt like i was on like a [ __ ] like
big brother episode like well this was
just [ __ ] never ended
it just never [ __ ] ended not gonna
lie okay we kept getting [ __ ] weirdos
yeah with this one
with this one okay admittedly i i don't
like oriemma like the show
but i think auri modes are hot as [ __ ]
yeah right
but here's the thing like this one
because it's because all the characters
are hot oh my god but here's the thing
right here's the thing with with this
particular one i've read a lot of worry
moderations i've never read this one
this one i was like okay first half i
was like okay this got kind of an
interesting story like
you kind of get to see like the
backstory of like the actual characters
it gets
[ __ ] weird and then second half like
she just like turns into a yandere yeah
so can you walk me through the story
like okay okay
let me i had to pull up the [ __ ]
armor to understand who the [ __ ]
everyone was notes foreign
so to explain the i guess i guess the
basic premise of orimo
as well so um so kierano
and kyosuke yep is the main the main
sibling pair
brother and then all you need to know is
also he has a childhood friend
who i don't even remember her [ __ ]
name uh the glasses
the glasses the one who's the wife
but basically those those are those are
like all you need to know about
the characters in this right so in the
ending of the original anime
um kierano uh kirito confesses to
kyousuke that which was like a [ __ ]
180 twist from like everything that was
built up before
right and then you know they have a few
dates together and then they decide
sister yeah yeah which you know they're
not blood related so
it doesn't count clearly
literally they can't keep getting away
with this the know you
the like brother or sister not blood
related [ __ ] man
oh shut up corner look you recommended
mother's no breasts yeah
that's literally a guy and his stepmom
that's just incest with an age gap
connor different it's different
no no no no it's not it's not she went
into
it's a different thing it's illegal
legally it's different
it depends if it's like the step brother
i don't know i could be like maybe
maybe but no but this one's like we're
literally they're literally brother and
sister and this is literally just the
like the [ __ ]
card they slytherin by the way like by
the way not blood related
goddamn what the [ __ ] her name what is
that just just google this was just
[ __ ] weird so explain
the story of this okay so i'll i'll
explain it
okay so this is this is like kind of
like a fan story
set 10 years after i got the understood
yeah 10 years that's why it's called 10
years after consultation or something
like that right
um so this is set 10 years after the
ending of the anime where it has like a
slightly different ending
um so in this version um
kirino and kyosuke sleep with each other
right and
their family finds out and kirino just
gets [ __ ] banished right and they
don't see each other
for 10 years understandable banish the
[ __ ] out of them
parents are doing what parents should do
exile your kid if they [ __ ] your sister
i guess
and so i guess this is set ten years
afterwards where she comes back
and um and they're both now married
he has married his childhood friend
which is like in the anime her like
minami is like
she's built up as like the plain girl
right she doesn't really have any
special things
all that will probably never win yeah
the girl that was never on the winning
list to begin with but she's she's built
up as just
the plane girl she's the childhood
friend right and
in this version he's the one that she
that she's the one that he ended up
marrying
and kirino has also apparently after 10
years married someone else
as well um and this is the first time
they've met
after 10 years and they think you know
they're
kind of like testing the waters to see
if you know they still have feelings for
each other
and it turns out um do i guess test the
waters with your brother and sister to
see if you still have feelings together
that feels like a very dangerous game
it's like russian
welcome to the incest tag bro literally
everything in this tag is that what if i
just like put my dick in your hand let's
just see if i get hard yeah like
that's a good task okay that's so [ __ ]
up
right okay so so to explain to explain
my tastes
right to explain
what i like why i why i thought this was
like
great because for one most parody
doujins they just like it's the most
vanilla [ __ ] storyline
like ever right it's just here's these
two characters
they sex you are watching it because
it's the characters you recognize but
this what i liked about this is that it
took the concept of orimo and it like
built on it and start like started its
own [ __ ] story i do appreciate that
element yeah yeah it was like this is
this was actually a really story heavy
dozen yeah yeah i mean i
unfortunately couldn't really appreciate
that because i didn't know [ __ ]
anything about the show
yeah i was just like this [ __ ] crazy no
yeah no i did like the fact that it
built on the law
of the original series that it was based
off of but just it took like a [ __ ]
depressing [ __ ] oh it was [ __ ]
depressing yeah right
like like kirino turns yandere and then
like threatens kosuke and then
mommy me gets like like right
it's like yeah it's like it's like this
this whole thing just kept getting
weirder and weirder so you know be me i
don't know
anything about this you know i don't
know anything about this series yeah
all i know is that he got banished for
[ __ ] his sister 10 years ago
and then they're like oh yeah we're
going to meet again immediately [ __ ]
it's like no no like no [ __ ] downtime
of course just made eye contact we [ __ ]
it
of course oh she's like i don't even
love my husband i love you and it's like
oh jesus well it's because they both
know what they want right yeah
no words necessary and i guess like for
me if i were to explain my taste
what i find hot is like when a taboo
gets broken
right it's it's it's it's like it's it's
not
i mean it's not the incest okay i was
about to say i'm pretty sure that's the
one so one reason every person who likes
the incest taxes
like what i hate about most incest
[ __ ] like most incest [ __ ] hentai
whatever
it's like it's like one girl says
oni-chan incest i'm like i'm just like
get that [ __ ] outta here you know
i don't give a sh i i don't give a [ __ ]
about it so you need the full backstory
of their their brotherly and sister
yeah yeah you're crushed in front of you
well it's it's it's it's not it's not
just between like
step siblings stepmother stepsons like i
like you know
two two co-workers who know they
shouldn't get together they get together
that's hot like a teacher-student
relationship that's pretty [ __ ] hot
as well because it's
oh i understand though it's it's like
it's like what i find hot it's like
two p two characters who know they
shouldn't get together
but they're too like they're too hot for
each other to be able to stop it and
they do it
even though they know it's wrong and i
know man to me like breaking it up
breaking a taboo is [ __ ] i totally
get that i think that's hot as well
but then this like but then there's the
scene where she just goes
like she just loses her mind for every
moment i thought maybe this could be hot
there's just something happened or i'm
like
god damn it this is fine that's so good
though it was just like so there's this
whole bit where
he's having sex with the girl yeah and
which girl
uh we're getting there's only two girls
there's only two goals yeah
yeah the other girl uh the boring one as
you said
yeah then she pulls out just a strap-on
for some reason
it just comes out of nowhere and it
feels like if this feels like
it just felt like the dlc being tacked
on at the end
and it was like you know you know what
this was so rushed in
and it happened for like one second and
then it was never mentioned again it was
never shown again
just she just had it with her you know
she's ready to go you know what i love
about that scene with the [ __ ] strap
on
where she like puts it into the wife and
she's like it's too big and then he's
like this is the same size as my big
brother's
like was he never i'm like was he never
serious with you and i'm like
oh my god that's a bird she just got
[ __ ]
burned dude this is the moment that like
really puzzled me the most i just didn't
understand why
yeah so you know he he [ __ ] his
step-sister or whatever sister and has
this whole thing and they have this
thing and he cheats on his wife and they
cheat on this wife and they have this
whole weird scene with that
she [ __ ] the his wife and stuff yeah i
don't really get why that's happening
um but at the end she's like by the way
i told mom again that we fought and i'm
like why
why did you eat it
i completely forgot about that i was
just assuming i'm like did you really
need to just tell your mom that you
[ __ ] your brother again what are you
trying to do jesus is like
what is this who does this i read that
and i was like
well that was unnecessary i was like
well this just went too far
your mom is probably just very nice
let's be real got dragged into this yeah
you've got to let her live her life
peacefully knowing that you were a good
satisfaction
bt dubs mom [ __ ] my brother and then
just leaves
and then leave peace what's wrong with
you what is wrong with you why did you
do this
i just couldn't fathom it it's like it's
like you don't see this in the
you know when you go on [ __ ] i don't
know one of these porn websites bang
bros or whatever and it's the whole mum
versus
sun step
there's not a whole scene at the end
we're like okay son i'm gonna tell dad
now
you know that i don't i don't want to
see that [ __ ] don't include that chick
cause i already feel guilty enough for
this [ __ ] don't include
this was supposed to be depressing right
it's yeah it's meant to be a depressing
dozen
really it's like if it was like scat
porn they're like right let's do 10
whole pages where they clean it up like
no no let's not do that after man
get their cling filled get the [ __ ] out
get the bleach we'll clean this place
no i don't want to see this [ __ ] this
felt totally unnecessary
why was this in the story like you
probably had to wrap it up how does this
wrap it up in any way
to be honest to be honest after like
right before
that whole thing happened no no right
before that whole thing ended in my head
i was like how are they going to end
this
and then do that and then that happened
i'm like well
i mean that's an ending i guess that
isn't it that's not the correct answer
okay the ending was a bit weird
that was a bit weird i mean like the
reason i really like these this dozen
was because like the first two chapters
um like when it started getting a bit
ntre i'm just like
uh you're kind of losing me here the
first time
yeah i think that wasn't the first time
it was because to me the first half was
so [ __ ] well done that i'm just like
okay i'm
i'm always going to remember this was
very good yeah i mean the r was good but
i mean to me it was the story art was
good and the way that they broke down
the law
was really good because it's so [ __ ]
rare for me to find
like hentai and the jin she actually
give a [ __ ] about the story yeah right
because like most like when when you
think of like for example most brother
sister hentai
it's just it's the most like simple [ __ ]
it's like
the sister comes in wakes up brother oh
no you're hard i guess i'll suck you off
now and i'm just like
like that's dodging over yeah that's
that's exactly i'm just like that's
literally
everything like who gives a [ __ ] about
that i'm like it's like cool
okay no i got a perfect thing i need
spice with my hentai okay
surprise surprise surprise surprise
incest is not spicy
fun incest has never been spicy
it's illegal i mean that's i mean that's
why steps
that's why it's always [ __ ] step
siblings in hentai right they love they
never go the full [ __ ] they never do the
full monty
right mother you'd be surprised
that's not the [ __ ] i watched joey's
like i can name it
i tell you what i can name like 10 off
the top of my head
the reason every hentai does it is
because it's like that disclaimer
that goes on like the beginning of every
youtube video was like this youtube
video is
fair use copyright this video is
protected under fair use
these things are not for your honor your
honor these siblings are simply steps
it is not illegal they are not blood
related they are just drawings
just in case you didn't hear me the
first time this episode is sponsored by
gamer socks did you buy anything yet why
didn't you buy anything yet but after
you've bought your gamer subs which
you've already done because you watched
the first promotion and already bought
them that's right yes
you did but once it arrives at your door
you'll notice that gamer subs is not
chalky at all
and there's no chemical aftertaste did
you know that you should because you've
already bought gamer subs
you need gamer subs get this [ __ ] into
me
gamer subs is zero calories zero carbs
and is non-glycemic so it doesn't touch
your blood sugar making it diabetic
and keto friendly no [ __ ] just a
hundred milligrams of organic caffeine
from green coffee beans and essential
vitamins to keep me
focused throughout my gaming period god
i'm gaming my
so much right now guys i have a
recommendation might i recommend the
newest flavor
waifu candy in my favorite new waifu cup
gamer subs waifu cups
for the perfect marriage between weaves
and gamers
that's a terrible slow we're not using
that back to the episode
i am just playing devil's advocate
because you know it's very easy to make
someone who says i like incest look bad
so it's very fun
i mean i don't know why it's so
surprising when it's when you're talking
about
gans i love domestic girlfriend giggup
you know
the man knows his taste man i know my
taste okay i respect that
yeah because to me like i said breaking
taboo that is my taste
unfortunately it's it's so [ __ ] hard
because 99
of hentai when it comes to like breaking
taboo are just like the most depraved
ntr [ __ ] you can find on like god's [ __ ]
i don't know i don't know there's so
much of it so many people are into it
man
you know i go you know you go on like
the hentai releases and yeah nowadays
it's like 60 to 70 percent of it it's
just ntr garbage
yeah that's like i can't nod to this
like like this
majority of japan is not like apparently
all i want to [ __ ] see
is two people who know they shouldn't be
together but just you know
for like one [ __ ] little rule break
have like a cheeky nando's you know have
a
have a cheeky little [ __ ] here and
there you know [ __ ]
you know have one or two hot nights and
then just doesn't need to know
and then just call it a day
unfortunately hentai takes us as
let's rip someone's life into pieces
while we do this that's what i wasn't
fond of with this one they were like i'm
just gonna i'm gonna tell mom
that that part really [ __ ] me up no no
why would you do that the part the
part that i that made the least sense to
me was just like you know like here and
i was just like i've left now i've fixed
their marriage i'm just like
in what way have you fixed that [ __ ]
marriage
i'm a matchmaker i fixed their marriage
by
literally getting my brother to [ __ ] me
all over his house
every part of his house we've had like a
threesome where we're just not going to
be able to talk about for years i'm not
getting busy
i'm not going to be able to look at my
wife in the eyes for like years to come
jesus imagine if we
imagine if we have kids like what the
[ __ ] i love how after that like a
[ __ ]
intense threesome scene and like kirino
leaves there's just like this monologue
of kyousuke being like
madami and i talked it out we're mending
our wounds
oh it's not easy isn't it oh [ __ ]
all right just be like that just be like
we just talked it out
you know babe i know i kind of just
[ __ ] my sister and
[ __ ] you at the same time um but i i
think
i think i think we can work through this
right happy wife happy life right
she's like yeah i'm good this is like
never happened before right
louie this is just a phase right
it's just the phase yeah totally yeah it
just happened one time right yeah
yeah the dna test results are coming
because like cause like when you see
cheating at hentai normally it's like
you're like the person is cheating
against this [ __ ] faceless dude that
you you don't see right it's like it's
like i'm not a fan of it
the character having an active part in
the story yeah you know i mean
that's the difference between cheating
and ntr you know yeah yeah yeah like
even [ __ ] kirino's husband comes back
at this even though he's like a faceless
[ __ ] guy just like
like where did that come from i love it
i mean it was just like i love the
ending scene too because he gets
absolutely
the [ __ ] kicked out of him and kiosk is
just like
worth it he's like right i'm still
protecting kirito i'm just like what
what is going on here
that would go how did that would go huh
but yeah the re the reason this is one
of my favorite
series like parody dojins of all time
it's because of the first two chapters
the first two chapters
10 out of 10. that is that is my exact
taste
i'm not gonna lie one thing that really
did put me off i didn't make a note of
this i'm like okay
why is he why is she being like he he
get me pregnant
but then be like uh no no that was
really [ __ ] weird can we can we admit
that that's kind of weird
okay shooting with your step brother is
really pushing it
what i could accept to be like oh he
hits hard yeah but then being like she's
like
make me pregnant literally the first
time she meets and i'm like what are you
supposed to think
what am i supposed to think here to be
like yeah that's hard dude
impregnate your sister that'll show him
that'll show everyone
i think this is i i you saying this now
i think this just shows that i've just
been so
sensitive
like because that because i feel like
that's just the [ __ ] that's that's
just the default in a lot of him
right there's always that one panel in
every hand side which just like make me
pregnant or i'm going to become pregnant
i am trying to be supportive of my
friends tasters
and i'm reading this you know and i want
to be like good for god
yeah but then like it's literally again
the amount of times i'm gonna reference
the [ __ ] headset meme where he rips
it off
i'm trying to get into this and she's
like make me pregnant i'm like [ __ ]
[ __ ] why why what do you mean
i think i think it's just because there
sometimes your tastes are like
like my taste is like so specific that
it's it's
it's kind of like i'm i'm willing to
look over some of like the weirdest [ __ ]
or the weirder aspects of some hentai if
there's like this aspect that it's done
like ridiculously ridiculously well
you know you sound like someone who's
like desperately digging for
good hentai after you've had it all
you're like i've seen something
i need to feel something i'll forgive if
i feel that you're the weird [ __ ]
[ __ ]
just for a crumb of good blow job if it
scratches through it
one tiny itch that's that's all i need
that's all i need this is [ __ ] weird
i did give this one a three out of ten
three three
honestly that was those very few moments
where i was like this is hot
and there's so many moments i'm like
[ __ ] out
[ __ ] like i i don't even smoke and i
wanted a smoke breakout
this is this is a dogen you read and
you're like i need a [ __ ] smoke
i don't even smoke and i was like [ __ ] i
need a cigarette just like [ __ ] look
out my window and just be like [ __ ] the
thousands
but i feel like that's to me that that's
what makes a great dojin like if
if if it can [ __ ] affect you in some
way then it's it
that means it really changes your life
no that means at least it's doing
something right right it's making you
feel something right
my biggest i'm just waiting for
something to happen it doesn't matter
what disgust anything i'll make it work
like anything
my dick is numb but my heart aches
[Music]
three out of ten where'd you go get this
one jerry
i don't know i weirdly enjoyed this one
um yes
[ __ ] yeah yeah oh my god this is why you
know we need we need a me on this
podcast to balance out the [ __ ]
degeneracy that we have over here
this is how i know joey's a brother i
really enjoy this one i'll give this
like a
that's probably seven or eight yeah god
damn it yeah story's spicy right again
it's a spicy story this is not
literally the word spice went out the
window when he told a [ __ ] mom that
was when i was like this is not spicy
that's like exact that's like by the
that's like the last [ __ ] panel
you should have already nutted by then
you don't give a [ __ ] about it
i don't wanna
clarity and then also find out
afterwards he told the mom yeah that's
like the biggest whiplash of posting on
clarity you'd be like you're like
oh god oh jesus that's not spice that's
like a carolina reaper to the eye
then for you personally nine oh my god
the
the good parts were so good that i'm
just like i it's
to me it's it's the most
like the most unique dough like parody
doesn't i've read so far in terms of
building on a premise and being able to
like take this premise in an anime and
just
make a hot situation just the dildo burn
did it for me like that
yeah yeah that was [ __ ] hilarious i
what does that mean in japanese
means to [ __ ] and peace peace peace is
peace
all right peace [ __ ] peace [ __ ] i'm fair
enough yeah
um so the premise of this one was a
strange one okay uh there was like i
guess uh
who's do you think it is first of all
yours yeah i thought it was yours this
seemed very much like a human thing
yeah but i also really really like the
plot to this one yeah i really enjoyed
the plot
i loved it yeah it was very good the
plot was good so okay first of all i did
read
the i was very very confused because it
came with like a
prequel yeah that's that's that's like
the youtube hook right right
where you have like a few pages to hook
in the reader where it was just like a
bunch of girls who have been taking
photos of who are naked
yeah and i was very confused and then
when i started reading it i almost
forgot for a second i was i was reading
and dojin because i thought i was about
to get some kind of sick [ __ ]
epic dojin about kendall
kendo fighting yeah and it very quickly
did became not that yeah yeah yeah yeah
like just for a second i totally forgot
that i was reading porn
yeah i was i thought this was like a
regular moment escaped into a regular
manga
you know there was this you have this
little you know the
the chad woman who is this amazing kendo
player very attractive very beautiful
and like the simp guy who's like this
very tiny very wimpy looking character
yeah yeah yeah and then
for some reason during the story she's
like oh please can you help me with
something yeah obviously the the wimpy
character is like yes of course i'll
help you
so they go to the office and there's the
guy who's in charge of the kendo club
who's engaged
but he's literally built like a
[ __ ] whale
on steroids like this man is absolutely
tall that's generous like 15 feet tall
muscular you know and he's like this is
my this is my fiance
yeah by the way i need you to take
photos of all the women
at the school all the graduates all
right all the graduates naked
rude being [ __ ] anything and then
there's just so many quotes in this are
just very funny yeah to me because
and then he's like oh is that a the
little wimpy characters like oh is it
okay that we take sexual photos of the
girls it's like
oh yes all the girls have given their
consent to this literally their
exit
tradition i'm like this is like some
youtuber cancel baby
how is this this is this is a tweet
longer waiting to blow up man how does
this become a long stance i want to know
that backstory
who started this how did everyone just
come to this cw
how did everyone give concerns i feel
like this needs to be like a signed form
or something
i really want to know more of this story
there must be an ironclad contract to
this yeah
release waivers yeah there's so many
funny uh
they have given their okay to this
that's what they said what i appreciate
about this dojon is that
i always appreciate a dozen where it
takes more than 20 pages to get to the
[ __ ]
yeah right i appreciate that a lot about
it because because i literally
experienced
two hours of just the worst [ __ ] i read
the armor one before this
i was begging for something that wasn't
[ __ ] awful
so this was a breath of fresh air
because the difference between a parody
dozen and an actual doujin is that
parody donations if you're a fan
of the show series you you can skip the
context because you know the context
you can build on top of that yeah but
like the the real challenge with just a
plain doujin
is that stuff
is that they need to build up your
investment into the story yeah by itself
with no pre-investment
any franchise or whatever and normally
that takes a long time and i can
appreciate when you go it went like 40
you want like a whole chapter i think
almost with no [ __ ] and i'm just like
respect respect restraint i appreciate
yeah exactly yeah one thing i really
liked about this one is that like the
whole
i guess point is that like obviously
he's gonna [ __ ] the main girl
yeah but they hold off on it for so
goddamn yeah i appreciate it wait so did
you read this whole thing
no i read uh about nearly two two
stories so
two chapters yeah because the first
chapter was like 150 pages no it wasn't
there's like six
parts to this there was if if you're
thinking of the 500 page one
those are 16 chapters put together yeah
oh well it was
it was when i looked at the website it
said six stories or whatever okay
so i mean i read up up until like how
many pages which way which goal did you
get to
which one i think you actually [ __ ]
the girl okay you got further than me
then which is like
i think it's like 200 pages in yeah but
then there's still like 400 more after
that yeah which i i didn't understand
but i was still like all right the
story's pretty hot because the whole
premise is that
he has to then go and he's recruited
this this
he's doing he's doing his job because
this whippy kid is recruited to take
all the naked and lewd photos yeah you
know and if he has to help to get the
photos done
he does yeah yeah so he just starts
[ __ ] everyone
i appreciate the hustle again i was like
you know what
good for him this is you're not you know
he was scared at first but then he gets
more and more confident yeah
you know titled like attractive
kid coming into his own getting getting
[ __ ]
good for him yeah good i was i was
rooting for him it's a coming-of-age
story
yeah and you know i thought it was very
attractive that she was watching the
whole time yeah yeah giving moral
support
who doesn't want that i love the scene
where she just like comes around and
grabs his dick and he's like you got
this
yeah yeah it was like irl twitch chat
yeah with [ __ ] you know it's like you
know it's like paul go in park take the
photo
i'm surprised you like this one because
i'm surprised you like this one as well
yeah this didn't okay because this one i
like i like the long game i like that
they were they were reserved with a lot
of things because this one is one of my
favorites like of all time yeah the art
style
threw me off a little bit it's unique
isn't it but then i got into it i was
like you know what i [ __ ] with it
that's exactly how i felt and then and
then you know because obviously you
can't just have the gimmick if he goes
to take a picture he [ __ ] them
don't get old yeah so then they start
introducing like these [ __ ] battles
yeah that's what i liked as well but i'm
just like this is so [ __ ]
dumb that i'm here for it the baiting
battles right yeah yeah yeah yeah
like bet on something yeah the first bet
is that he has to choose
what he thinks is her favorite volumes
of her like lewd outfits am i correct
yeah yeah so she's like
uh like a graveyard model who does like
sexual stuff and she's like
pick two or pick two things that i
consider my best works and he's like
easy game yeah and then if you picked
them out i was already a super fan
yeah and he's like yeah and he's like if
you lose you throw out all of your porn
if you win you get to [ __ ] me and he
gets the [ __ ] so congratulations
there was another one where they did
like wishbone breaking
oh yeah yeah with the grass that's like
a really old japanese game
yeah and then he wins i that this
20-foot kendo man is like
um he's so powerful he's won two betting
games
this kid's good and it's like it's like
we need more food like he literally
guessed
dojins and then played wishbone a lucky
game what do you think
yeah yeah and it's just like he might
get all the photos this year
implying that some of them don't want
their photos taken which is like i was
like oh that's a little weird but i'll
forgive it but it was supposed to go
go some of the later chapters it does
become like that yeah i i thought you
know what fair enough it was
i i see the vision yeah i appreciate the
execution
what all around good fun for the family
what i love about
yeah cheers
for the most part i think i i didn't get
far enough i'm sad you didn't make it to
like the
pretty much like the the finale or like
the enemy part i might refuse to epic
because there's like a whole
[ __ ] there's like three chapters where
there's a hot there's three chapters
where
the wimpy kid the main character fights
the student council brick [ __ ] in a
wrestling
okay i know they were building up yeah
yeah it was very obvious that that was
gonna be the finances
while that's happening all of the girls
that he's [ __ ]
are getting like gang banged by the
entire school
and he's like if you want to stop this
beat me in a wrestling match and i was
just like
you know you know i was like you know
after reading all of
all of joey's recommendations like i
like figured out joey's tastes
like if there's he recommends a dozen if
there's a panel on it with more than
like eight tits in one panel
that's that's a joey true that's a joke
joey
yeah yeah you're right
i can't you know i'm mad that you're
right the more the merrier yeah
but like what i love about a story in a
dojo like this is when like they
introduce
the one winning girl at the beginning
sure yeah yeah yeah i mean she's
the hottest you know she's higher yeah i
i don't know how like dojian artists
they just know they know they know i'm
going to make this girl the hottest
there's something about a supporting
girl yeah you just you can't help but
root for
you know you're like is just helping
she's just doing her part yeah
[ __ ] it yeah literally yeah it's like
they must have like
a talent to be able to like make a girl
that you know is like
just radiates best girl energy right
like
they just radiate best girl energy and
everyone just unanimously agrees that
this is best girl and every every girl
is just like the losing girl so honestly
she wasn't okina who's the the artist
he's like
[ __ ] amazing at that because all of
his other ones he always introduces this
like
beginning girl yeah and whether like she
gets [ __ ] in the beginning or right at
the end
she always ends up being the best girl
because yeah throwback to the
the hentai episode uh the one thing that
i did like about that one thing that you
picked
even though i didn't particularly which
one uh the one that was like the
edo era japanese oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
i was like that's the one
i was at least at least like the fact
that they took three episodes to build
that [ __ ] up before yeah
you know yeah i like it when they tease
you yeah like
you know because you know you can go on
[ __ ] pornhub
and you can you can skip two minutes in
you're already at the [ __ ] meat
yeah yeah yeah i like it when they make
you wait for it something yeah
it's like it's like you're making me
feel like these characters are worth it
you know what i mean
yeah cause when they immediately put
their pants down and he's [ __ ] two
other women i'm like i'm not investing
he's like you've lost me
it's a no for me yeah i like i like
being able to wait to see
the best girl you know i'm impatient
yeah i'm patient
oh you know i'm i'm also impatient
sometimes i'm just like let's just skip
to episode
five and let's just see it okay like and
then but like i feel like
the best times is like when you know
there's a reason to turn the next page
there's
there's a reason to like watch the next
episode like it's it's new it's like
metal gear solid the best is yet to come
to consider the plumber turning up a
riveting story yeah
worth me turning the [ __ ] page yeah
yeah oh i'm investing
what what part of the house is he gonna
face oh [ __ ] is it
which kind of clog is it i'm [ __ ]
hyped to see what kind of clothes it is
honestly all the size wrenches here is
a grease clog or a [ __ ] toilet paper
claw i can't wait
you know what i mean it's i think that's
the one thing that at least i can
appreciate about the durgin is that you
can you can
kind of almost if there's a story you
can kind of read it in your own pace and
yeah get the feel for it that you want
i i can i can i can respect that i wish
that i could read it
and then the moment the [ __ ] starts
i'm like turn on the hand-tied version
yeah
well this one actually does have a hint
yeah i was about to say this one does
have an entire
say that is it bad it sounds bad it's
queen bee ah
i'm gonna watch it all right i i'm
actually
curious about your opinion i'm actually
i'm actually curious about your opinion
now that you're gonna go from like a
dozen
to an adaptation of that direction
because you enjoy it because there's
another one
by snooki now that i was debating on
whether to recommend called new to
speech
which is i've i love the nudist speech
the hentai it's great yeah yeah that's
that's
the same guy yeah i like that yeah
that's like and the the dojin version is
like
one of my favorites and also kaho's
favorite oh yeah we like bonded over
that but like i was like
do i recommend it but like piece of
harmony just has a better story in my
opinion i like the story a lot yeah and
when i like started
with nudist beach i was you know when i
watched that originally i was like you
know what
you know what you can you watch
something you just know this is popular
yeah yeah
i'm like i know this one i don't know
anything about hentai or dojin community
and what the [ __ ] they get up to but
i've watched that and i'm like
i bet this is famous as [ __ ] yeah just
from watching this i'm like this [ __ ] is
too
who adopted new to speech again queen
bee no it wasn't it was good adaptation
though
was it i thought it was queen no i swear
i watched that and it was good
i don't i don't think it was queen bee
really i swear it was a good
adaptation let's see but i gave this one
um what did i give this one
uh i used a 9 out of 10. really
i i genuinely i dig the story honestly
that's really surprising i thought you
would hate this one
cheers to that cheers
we are we are two for four i think two
for four two for four right now we're
slowly converting him
we're slowly converting here i'm not
gonna say i'm gonna go home and read
this [ __ ] oh
it's my preferred yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah of course if you're gonna
sit here and force me to read this [ __ ]
okay here's the question then like if
you had just experienced this through
the hentai
would you have would you have watched
through the scene yeah for sure for sure
really i mean most entire watch this
story
really because it's like 19 minutes it's
not it's not a big ask
that's the most uncommon thing yeah
because in the
history of this podcast okay you know
when you uh i don't know if you do this
right okay i gotta ask
when you when you're when you you know
you're doing your business yeah yeah
yeah
if you you know you finish your business
yeah
and there's like six minutes left do you
just save it for another time the rest
six minutes or do you just keep watching
and see what else happens save it i save
it yeah me too me too
[Music]
it takes restraint but i'm like you know
what no i could skip ahead and find the
best part yeah but no no no
this is fresh content next time connor i
agree
because you don't want to spot you get
you get so limited you know i've
realized with hentai is literally like
you know it's like mining for diamonds
in minecraft you just don't get it
that's what i'm saying that's what i'm
saying you don't get the good [ __ ]
it's like when you find a good [ __ ] when
you find one of the good [ __ ] you got to
save that yeah
there's like 10 hentai that i can
probably i could be like you know what
these are probably my favorite that yeah
yeah but like they never come around
because because we have so much goddamn
ntr
it's [ __ ] it's awful and at the
moment we don't get ntr you know
as much as i you know i can get i can i
can work with queen bee
but i don't like it where every single
non ntr is queen bee yeah
honestly what's happening here can we
not do this for ten seconds because i
was because just
imagine me when i go on to just like a
regular hentai website and i see
peace episode one i was like my time has
come
my favorite hentais finally when did
they come out uh the dojin or the hand
hentai a couple years ago yeah it was
quite it's quite quite recent
i mean um i wonder i'm like is japan
just a head on porn like are they just
are they speed running it is this where
all porn is going to go to where
everyone in the world is going to be ntr
fans
god because i really [ __ ] hope not
because i feel like they're like five
stages ahead of like [ __ ] up [ __ ]
yeah oh yeah i mean it's because japan
just accepts any kind of [ __ ] up
hentai right are we
is this what the world is going towards
are we all going to be ncr
are we all going to be empty in 20 years
here's the thing there's obviously
someone out there watching ncr
a lot of people a lot of people i
actually know
someone i just [ __ ]
well there you go point point taken
you you the thing is that it is like you
literally just proved your own point
you know ncr you know sometimes is
attractive
you know i will admit there are one or
two i'm like you know what they had me
in the first time it's not all about
which ones
i can't remember the top of my head
there have been one or two where i'm
like you know this is good but then i'm
like ah it's ntr they're not gonna not
gonna do it
because i'm like you know what like does
this vanilla really have to die because
i feel like
vanilla is the minority of hentai that
we get now it's very rare
you just get a oh my they they like each
other
there's no cheating there's no sibling
rivalry
oh my god i think it's because in the
context of i do
japanese okay i think it's because in
the context of japanese audiences who
read it
it's like why would i read this when i
could just have it myself
actually get out there okay but like but
like with with your vanilla thing
do you count for example step siblings
or step
parent stepmother whatever if there's no
other complications
other than them for some reason just
being step siblings or stepmother
is that vanilla to you i'd say yeah
probably yeah i mean that's pretty
vanilla i mean that's pretty that's
that's probably the most vanilla you can
get nowadays yeah i mean all right
because the thing is because the thing
is it's it makes it even rarer right
because
you go on any porn website now it is
literally all
stepmom everything everything is step
really yes are you sure or is that just
the [ __ ] you look up
no no no i i kid you not you go on this
[ __ ] and all the most viewed [ __ ] it's
all step-by-step
and i'm like i'm like what is happening
i'm here for it but like when did this
happen i don't know when it happened
right
you you know right like i i see it too i
think wait melin can you search up some
of the most
searched terms on pornhub like because i
i guarantee i think stepmoms
okay ashley ashley actually actually i
guaran like i think it's
either top three or top five because
stepmom is up there what happened
because i swear like five six years ago
lesbian porn was always number one yes
it was never dethroned and then all of a
sudden out of nowhere in like the space
of two years
all the [ __ ] up [ __ ] goes to the top
what happened
in those two is this coronavirus where
people are like i guess ntr's pretty
good
i'm looking up the most popular tags for
doujins right now and uh
would you believe that milf is in the
top 20.
i hope so but do you know what's
directly on top of that what
insists
it's concerning no this is not a
celebratory moment i will take my crown
right now
oh but then you know what fellow
degeneres rise up
degenerates rise up man there are some
like oh my god number 10 is
shotokon actually you're literally
looking on pornhub
just search tops just search god
just touch the top
boss is sitting right next to you and
you're on pornhub
what are you doing stop corrupting
ashley like this
what if the most searched terms are like
in the past it's literally they do it
like a survey yeah they do a survey they
literally do a survey and they're like
uh
speaking of show to come do we get on to
the next one yeah sure let's go on to
the next one
do you want to know the 2019 number one
was amateur
number two was alien so those were the
those were the searches
search terms search terms they're there
that's what you're going for
[Music]
japanese number one number one number
two is hentai
number three is lesbian number four's
milk hentai is above lesbian now
what what's number five oh there it is
no korean i swear it's like nearly like
you go on these websites it is like
russia driving half of this wait
where's stepmom okay
i'm milf though stepmon and milford
normally very like close yeah yeah
but also dude if you look at it the
amount of people in russia that watch
hentai is insane
really hentai is massive in russia it's
insane [ __ ] i need to move to russia
putin's like put mother knows best on my
90-inch oled tv
my italian leather couch or my polar
bear rug
so yeah the next one yeah it's say cats
to shoe
yeah i'm near certain gant recommended
this one it was me
are you i'm not gonna lie i'm saying
right now boys yeah
i like i like the hentai version of this
one yeah the hentai version is funny
because
yeah dude you can't the animation alone
in the in the hentai version of this is
so goddamn good
and i was so confused when i opened this
dojin because i was like what is this
story in the start
yeah this is the [ __ ] story get to the
story i know yeah the
good story yeah because the first story
is just like
yeah this is like so this is like a
collection of stories it's like is it
two stories it's like two or three
stories okay so there's two stories in
this it's second to shoot
and uh i think it's so the first part is
like a teacher
who [ __ ] their student story yeah yeah
yeah and like this teacher is not
not very charismatic very creepy very
rapey
really weird you know you get into this
girl and she's a little concerned you
know
she's like why are all the guys looking
at my my my big you know
big big big donkeys and uh you know
and this teacher's like oh don't worry
about it i'll help you i'll help you get
used to them yeah because
if you don't care about it anymore no
one's going to look at them
and i'm like genius logic
okay and so he's like oh yeah just take
your bra off in front of me so you can
get more used to showing them off and
i'm like
oh god all right it's one of these
because it's just like it's really rapey
and like
because they because you get you did
recommend the next one we'll talk about
is teacher one
i think that's done much more tastefully
than this yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah not a
fan of this one shot
yeah the one shot i didn't really want
you to care well the one shot was like a
hundred pages long though
because it's like and this is the thing
that i hate about hentai
but this happens all the goddamn time um
let me see it so so
okay one one trope that i really am not
fond of in hentai is where the girl is
like
no oh my god please don't and like
they're clearly being
i mean you know sexually assaulted
really yeah yeah and then suddenly the
you know they start doing it and they're
like oh wait i like this now and i'm
like i don't think that's how yeah
why haven't you bought gamer sub [ __ ]
what is going on did you not know that
this episode was sponsored by gamer
subscribes now and you haven't bought
gamers
the coupon code is trash taste what are
you doing we're not wearing these shirts
for nothing for me once shame on me
for me twice shame on you for me three
times i don't even know who to blame
anymore
do we not convince you enough are we not
gamer enough for you
have you not tried their newest flavor
waifu candy
it's delicious what's wrong with you
guys come on look at these waifus look
at all these beautiful waifus that you
can choose from to get your gamer juice
from
come on gamers they have free samples
they have free samples thank you
guys i know you haven't clicked the link
yet and that's fine that's fine you know
i'm not angry i'm not angry but
maybe this will entice you joey tell
them what it is okay
did you know the first five thousand
people to click the link add the samples
to their carts and check out with code
for re we'll get free samples delivered
to them
no [ __ ] that is the last chance this
is your last chance i'm telling you
now what am i your mom go buy gamer subs
your mum will love these cups i'm not
angry
i'm just disappointed if you don't click
the link right now click the link in the
description down below
back to the episode generally did not
enjoy this teacher fellow
i thought he was a little bit a little
bit rapey a little unpleasant
yeah and like like i think i said it's
an entire episode not really fond of
that kind of stuff
you know to me it's just like ah okay
and he's like i'm gonna teach you how to
be more comfortable with your boobs i'm
like
are you really yeah are you sure about
that did you say like the name of the
dojin
i'll tell you the name of the dojian is
abstinence club at least the first story
arc right
which is it's it's obviously nothing
about abstinence
i'm sorry no abstinence to be found here
that's quite the opposite
you know these are not good christian
girls you know that's that's not what
we're talking about here
and there's two things that personally i
i i i'm not really fond of or i just
i'm like oh whatever that come up in
this the sturgeon uh
first one being uh that apparently dick
can just convert your feelings entirely
and that you can just suddenly love it
once it's inside of you i'm like
pretty sure that's not how it works uh
whatever it's gonna be a pretty [ __ ]
good dick for you to do that you'd be
surprised about
how many times that pop that crops up in
hentai
[ __ ] where it's just like huh you
don't want it well
you have you obviously haven't had the
giga chad let me introduce you say that
after you feel like
it's so [ __ ] dumb i hate it so much
yeah and then also they have that whole
[ __ ] trope of uh for some reason this
happens a lot in hentai as well where
um you know the girl is having sex with
the teacher because of course she is
yeah and outside is another student who
happens to catch wind of this going on
and naturally instead of being like oh
god oh my god and running away and
telling friends she's like
i think i should i think i should start
nutting i think i should start
masturbating right now
right now outside outside multiple times
either winter or summer in japan which
are both wildly uncomfortable seasons to
be doing this outside by the way
so this is just a terrible experience
overall and i did not enjoy this first
story or i thought it was [ __ ]
and i was really confused i was like i
meant i really liked the anime version
of this i thought it was really hot
i i didn't even remember this that this
had an anime adaptation because like i
had to like
i was i was seeing it no no exactly
because i i was like this name kind of
rings a bell the same thing i look at
the anime and then i look at the dojin
and i'm just like
these aren't the same yeah i literally
thought i had made a mistake
and like they adapted the better half
yeah yeah
thanks thankfully because the first half
is every other [ __ ] dojin that exists
yeah yeah and every hentai alright
whatever [ __ ] teacher abuses power
yeah
yeah yeah whatever whatever we'll get to
okay let's let's get to the part you
want to talk about this okay let's get
to the good part the animated adaptation
of this one
i have seen i enjoy thoroughly yeah i
think it's great the animation
very good because because the boy
isn't actually a shotokan makes it in my
head i'm like
free pass i'm like it's free real estate
because he transforms temporarily so
yeah i'm willing to bend the rules
this is like this is like if i close my
eyes and forget it's conor's voice
coming out i'm just like
man is joey [ __ ] talking about what
what is what is going on yeah that
that's like
that's that's like that's like are you
okay with shoulder conscious that way
you're saying no
i have watched i don't know what that
other famous one is that always comes up
with like the
big big milfs and the tiny tiny kids
that i do the yokai one hate that one
that one is [ __ ] disgusting yeah and
i accidentally watched it and i thought
oh
god oh you know what i'm on about if
you've seen it it's
it's this vile it's like an eight-foot
mill for us yeah yeah yeah [ __ ]
disgusting
because it's it's it's like [ __ ]
watching attack on titan you know what
the man
it's like a pov
i was just like i this this this dojin
disappointed me
so [ __ ] much right and and the hentai
also disappoints me
because you know why do you know what
the worst do you know the only thing
worst thing than a lolly
a shotokan i agree though i agree
because
because the thing is with lollipop in my
hate right
cause like no no they're not equal to me
because with lolly hentai i was like i
was never gonna jack off to you anyway
it's whatever i can just skip over this
the one reason why it's so [ __ ] hard
to find milf hentai is because 90
of them are shotokan and the thing is
most of them have like the [ __ ]
hottest milf like perfectly crafted
milf from ghost crafted yeah yeah
i i don't think there's that many i
think you're over exaggerating
that's what it feels like to me right
and i'm just like all right i'm in this
i'm invested i'm ready for the center
and then the [ __ ] shoulder comes out
and i'm just like
you are this you are this close to
greatness
we had it and then you lost it they had
us in the first half
you know i i can understand the
frustration yeah but i think this is an
exception
hell yeah you know if i if i'd read the
doji and i thought
so what show what another another like b
tier
but you watch the anime version you're
like this has a place
i'm like okay now we're talking now
we're talking
this is such a one like this is such a
shyamalan twist for me because i thought
you were gonna hate this one
no i i do how can how when you watch the
animation of this one because it has a
lowly
shoulder in it okay the lolly one i
thought was i don't know i really like
the red head girl yeah the red hair goes
hot yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
i was just like redheaded girl it's
[ __ ] hot yeah shoda
why why i think it's like it's it's like
if you have the [ __ ] mona lisa and
you just decide to [ __ ] piss on it
you know do you ever do you ever see
something that happens in porn that it
like
it like hits something where you're like
oh i didn't know i was into that but
that's
very nice yeah that's like that's that's
what i like search for every day
try and try to fill that craving every
day you know the
there was a scene in it where she like
gives a hand job at the dinner table i'm
like i don't know why that was very
attractive but i was like
i'm the red head girl i'm into that yeah
i'm like you've sold me i want to invest
how do i invest in this put my money in
this stock stocks
to the moon that kind of [ __ ] i'm like
i'm here for it but like i know it's
terrible because it's like my body
my mind's telling me but my body
it's like it's like literally that it's
like i know i know this is [ __ ] and i
you know i'm always very very hard on
you guys for this kind of [ __ ] so i feel
like it's very hypocritical
well i mean i'm just happy we found out
that you have a new favorite face which
is cheeky hand job under the table
honestly cheeky hand job at the family
table yes
what's a better genre i like danger
in in mine you like a bit of spices
i like i like danger not spice i don't
want to go i don't know
that's me that's like danger i like the
fact that anyone could walk in i like
that kind of [ __ ] right
that kind of stuff like having a danger
wank that's what he did
i'm not out here in the [ __ ] the taxi
wanking
i'm not saying that but a little bit of
spice a little bit of danger a little
bit of danger
adds a little something to danger
but also every single you know again
like my my love for
for like this thing is purely based on
the this is not even a doji thing at
this point the dojin was mid when i was
reading it right
okay so review because because you are
talking about the animation right the
animation is
so goddamn i think pineapple like finna
bring my a game
yeah for some reason i completely agree
watching the
animation of this the animation for
hentai stan is
[ __ ] god what happened i knew i
didn't know what happened this is also
like
[ __ ] i i'm surprised that no one
recommended this on our hentai episode
right because it's it's just that famous
i was going to but then i thought he
would hate it no i like this one
because i was like i don't know if
connor's into shoulder or not no
i'm not most of it i absolutely this is
probably the only one where i'm like
that's hot
really yeah this is the only one i've
ever seen that i'm like i think this is
good that's really surprising
i'm learning a lot about you today what
can i say you know
i'm willing to bend my morals all right
so just so purely just based on the
dosion out of ten
like a six six yeah it was like the
first story really ruined it
her story was so basic so bland so
insulting none of the characters were
hot the teacher was [ __ ] just
not even remotely attracted i was not
into the teacher character at all
and we'll get into the next teacher
character what i'm getting out of this
is like what if like [ __ ] ufotable i
animated some lolli hentai
would conor enjoy it because the
animation's that good i don't know
i was saying i like my hentai animation
bad because
sometimes i feel like you did it just
like completely because
sometimes i feel like it serves the
story better to have like bad animation
because sometimes the [ __ ] isn't that
great and i'm like you know what it's
funny we are talking to
the one and only fan of milky right but
for this this is one of them where i'm
like the animation is so goddamn good
where it feels like this is better than
most anime we've been getting recently
so it's like what am i supposed to do no
wrong how can i hate on this this is
just so god damn good
i'm not saying i want all hands to be
like this because when god knows we'd
get 50 ntrs animated like this and
my mind can't take that yeah that would
be 50 fortunately the ntrs are like some
of the best
they are they always [ __ ] hate it i
hate it it's like
they draw this ugly bastard with the
detail of a mona lisa
and it's like why would you do this what
is wrong with you
how is the staff okay doing this like i
just don't get it
but it's fine they're just playing nut
chicken right because
it's it's just like it's just like are
you willing to nut to this are you
willing to not with his animation we
can't always have a masterpiece
i've accepted that not everything can be
a masterpiece you know literally the
animation watch it's great uh but yeah
this is good i like the animation
the story was kind of [ __ ] but the
animation very much saves the story
you just reviewed the enzyme what they
do essentially i mean i
genuinely when i go to the second heart
i'm like seen it skipped it yeah
i already know exactly what happens i
went through like sure it was like one
for one the same as well
was there a reason why you suggested
this doujin
um it's just the first one i thought of
when i thought like
you know all the girls are hot like it's
just an interesting premise like
yeah i don't know like again this is
another one where it's like as long as
you're okay with the whole showdown
thing it's very inoffensive
that's a very big ass just get over the
shoulder it's fine
just pretend you're the shoulder it's
all right i don't know is it one of
those things
like is it because i'm a guy where i can
forgive it a little less
is that why is that what do you mean
like with the shoulder in this case
am i making an exception because i'm a
guy and i could be like you know he was
an adult in the start of this this thing
right but if he was like a full-on kid
he was genuinely a kid i
i don't think i could do it i mean this
is this is like a very
deep conversation that i don't feel we
have time to explore
on this podcast maybe maybe at a later
maybe maybe on a future podcast it's
definitely one of those things where i'm
like
i i hate letting the exception like i
hate letting them be like the uno
reverse card
kind of save it but like for this one
i'm like
kind of does though for me like he acts
like it like
an adult he is an adult all right [ __ ]
it all right i'll let it but like
the thing that the the thing that turns
me off originally was that
he didn't know that he wasn't a showdown
they like you know the girls didn't know
that he wasn't sure
do you think it was weird when i first
watched it that's suddenly into him now
that he's a kid i'm like yeah
because all the kills are in the show
and i'm like there's a few things wait
wait wait wait
so it's kind of like when you have the
siblings [ __ ] but then they
but then they'd be like by your step
siblings
because
there was no moment where she was like
i'm gonna ruin your life i'm gonna
impregnate you
impregnate me ruin my marriage there was
none of that that's pretty [ __ ] hard
to deal with i don't want a marriage
just being ruined well i'm trying to
have a wank
like you know what i mean that's not
what i want to do all right let's get on
to let's get on to the last one
or the second last second all right
second last one which is uh
teacher and student yeah uh so this
one's obviously god's because
this one's mine you know what i had this
down as gaunt actually
oh okay i'm perfect again like i'm i'm
shocked i got some of these wrongs i
thought
i got them yeah i'm shocked you got it
wrong too i thought it would have been
fairly obvious
uh i thought it was fairly obvious it
was just because you know it was because
we got in the conversation the other day
where god mentioned the word showter and
i'm like this is gonna be gone
he said the word he said literally set
the word shouted at me like a week ago
it must be gone
he's trying to [ __ ] inception my ass
yeah i mean what is this this one was
weird
because i thought the premise was really
quite attractive you know i thought it
was quite hot
and then suddenly things just started
happening where i'm like oh
i don't know i don't know about this
really because let me explain the
premise
yeah uh so a teacher who works at the
school
is broke i guess very broken very broke
she has a very broken full-time
full-time you know teacher
obviously yeah obviously some pain the
dog seems like everyone else is managing
fine
so her genius solution is to ask one of
the kids
whose dad owns an apartment complex he's
a rich kid
to just stay in his house and uh you
know so he says no
because he's a very responsible chad
child he says no he says no to this
woman you know no you're my teacher you
can't stay in my [ __ ] apartment yeah
yeah
why the [ __ ] would you so she turns up
at his door
naturally as you do when you've been
rejected just [ __ ] turn up at that
door
this is already extremely wildly
inappropriate for hr standards
yeah uh and just invite yourself in uh
and then she just starts living with him
and mad props to the kid pushes her away
and says no
like ten times that has to be that has
to be
rewarded perhaps king [ __ ] but
it's a dojin you could only last so long
yeah but the fact that he said no a
bunch of times i respect that
right expecting you know he's respecting
the hr standards of the workplace yeah
frankly for a kid very professional yeah
yeah
i noticed uh i'm calling hr how did this
woman get this job
that's what i did write down um because
she's essentially just trying to [ __ ]
this guy constantly and i'm just
wondering like
how does she get this job what's going
on here what's
what's going on here what we did a
sneaky uh hand job on the
table guy from what i remember she
definitely did
did she yeah she literally grabbed his
dick out and started sucking oh yeah the
phone no no
that that was the first time that was
the first time before that
even before she even came to his house
she's like do you want to touch my boobs
i'll let you do it if i get to stay in
your house no but she said like joking
yeah cause she's like supposed to be
like a [ __ ] teacher she can't say
that
[ __ ] jokey leave this student it's a dog
wait can i have a can i have a beer
actually can you yeah can you give me a
beer as well from the fridge and the
beer for this [ __ ] yeah i can't get it i
gotta talk
i'll talk about this [ __ ] without a
drink you could run out of wine
all right so so to explain
why i guess to give context to why i
chose this um
this is one of my favorite dojin artists
um
it's an artist called fuga and i don't
think
yeah i didn't know how well known he was
but this man
is to me the king of vanilla yeah like
this man's like his art is like i would
say like about average maybe a bit above
average
average
it's about average but like why i love
his work so much is that
his like stories and characters are so
[ __ ] good
where there are some points where i feel
like i'm not even reading a dozen i'm
just i'm just reading
uh romance manga with sex scenes i wanna
i wanna agree with you so bad i want it
but there was so many moments where i'm
like
nah bro this is it the ancestors
let me explain the story first and i'll
build up to
you're probably wondering why is that
incest in this story this doesn't
no connor didn't even mention it says
why is there incest in this story great
question
i'll answer why that's interesting this
story so in this story like i said you
know she moves into his apartment
for some reason he doesn't kick her out
or try to get like his dad to kick her
out
yeah he lets her live in there and you
know they both explain to each other
they're frustrated because they haven't
been able to jack off because they're
both
always around each other right yeah and
so her her solution is well great i'll
just make you not
yeah as any good teacher
apparently so they start [ __ ] and
then it becomes a thing and you know
it's it's very honestly like i will
admit it's quite attractive
up to this point yeah it's it's done
very tastefully considering the fact
that it would be very illegal
yeah and very concerning in real life in
dojin form
very tasteful i thought it was done
really well i was on board i would say
the reason for that is because like
there's a good like 40 to 50 pages
before there's this first section
true and like it's not well it's like
you hear this premise
and you think okay i've seen doge's like
this before they [ __ ] with like the
third fourth page or something no they
there is like it was tasteful there is
40 full pages of characterization
and that's the thing that that's why i
love this ghosting artist is because he
gives a [ __ ] about characterization
i'll say that there was he definitely
took the time and again like i'm saying
like
you know obviously in real life the [ __ ]
[ __ ] is [ __ ] weird yeah yeah but it's
turned you know
you set the kind of disbelief apart and
it and it was done really well i'd say
up to this point it's done really well
don't know what you're saying
no i was just gonna say i [ __ ] love
this one i don't again
i was honestly i was so into this i was
like this reminds me of like
an early 90s shonen jump wrong call yeah
it does
like with like the art and like how it's
pacing like the characterization i'm
like i [ __ ] love this i'm not just
here to hate you know
i agree it was hot right yeah up until
this point i was like they're hitting
every mark you know yeah
they've done this about as tastefully as
you can a little was it chapter three
it might have been chapter two so first
first of all right we get this whole
like i mean the whole reason why they
[ __ ] is because uh
there's a rumor going around the school
that she's dating a teacher yeah and the
teacher's like like the vice principal
vice principal yeah
and the vice principal was like yeah
we're dating kid get over it
yeah he doesn't know they're [ __ ]
yeah and she's like no no no
he tried to attempt to hotel and he
tried to come on me we didn't [ __ ] yeah
yeah
all right respect respect i get it yeah
and then out of nowhere
like like [ __ ] randy orton slithering
in his sister comes into the play
and is like by the way i love him i'm
gonna [ __ ] him now
and then they start [ __ ] and i'm like
what is going on
where did this come from why why why
it's like it's like this
this incest was just like allow me to
introduce myself
like why did this wind up it wasn't
allow me to introduce myself it came in
like the kool-aid man it was
yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly like like to
this day
out of nowhere they just start [ __ ]
his sister and then she leaves and it's
never brought up again
why why not like
so much what the [ __ ] i [ __ ] hated
the incest in this one okay god what the
[ __ ] was that the reason i
[ __ ] love this one teacher student
relationship done [ __ ] tastefully as
[ __ ] yeah um
like this like okay chapter three he
like she doesn't [ __ ] the main guy
for some reason like there is just this
like one of his classmates comes in and
is just like
i've run away from home and that's right
but it was
that was weird too this my sister is
harassing me
okay so to correct what connor said it's
the sister
doesn't [ __ ] the main guy it's just
these two side characters
who just ran who is the brother sister
who just randomly [ __ ]
for no [ __ ] reason i don't know why
he's the main character no no no no no
no no
no no it's not the main character
it's the main character's friend yeah
it's the main character but list chat
yeah yeah it's like the main character's
friends shows
up and he says i've run away from home
and then he finds out how to [ __ ] me
yeah yeah
my sister's been harassing me and then
heath and then so
this is even more concerning because it
has absolutely nothing to do with that
the main story right
friend finds out that the teacher and
student are living together
and he's like oh okay that's fine
whatever and then the sister comes along
and
and was like the sister comes to the
teacher and is like do you know where my
little brother is
i heard he went to your place or
something along those lines and so the
sister comes in
and she's like this is this is mine he's
mine yeah and then she and then
i don't think i don't even know who he
is
then the little brother starts like and
then she starts [ __ ] sucking his dick
or something in front of the teacher and
the teacher's just there
being like all right you guys you do
the teachers just like [ __ ] mike was
ousting face just like
this is why i was like i was like what
the [ __ ] was that like i was
literally into this headset meme
what is this like why do they do this
like every time you get into it
a random side story comes up there's
absolutely [ __ ] nothing to do with
the story
and it's [ __ ] i thought that side story
was [ __ ] hilarious
it
i mean i mean i it was i it was so out
of place
for like the rest of the dojo because
there's only one chapter
it's only one chapter it's a side story
that i don't know why this side story is
in here what is it at the end
put it at the end because it literally
it literally had no effect on the story
and the character they don't call back
to the characters i [ __ ] know
like i don't know why this side story's
in here but the point is like
the reason this is one of my favorites
is that the relationship the
relationship between the student and the
teacher
is like so well and it's just like you
you don't
you can never read a booga dojin and
just not come out
just like with a warm fuzzy feeling
i agree i agree with whoa i agree with
that what is what what what are you
laughing at corner
why why are you laughing connor because
there's there's a few there's a
god i gotta stop you right there i will
stop you right again there is one moment
where i was like oh i don't know about
that one chief
well she's like she's like guys i have
an announcement to the school
i've been [ __ ] one of the students
and i'm like
i don't think that's a good idea i
really don't think this is okay well
like
it's completely in character though
isn't it like they've built her up as
just someone who just doesn't give a
[ __ ]
yeah but i'm thinking i'm sitting here
like all right all right i did it for
love i respect it i respect
i do yeah yeah i do but i think about
your career a little bit no she doesn't
know she's
not employed literally just admitted to
a criminal offense i'm pretty sure like
in front of everyone no dude she was
just like
i love this guy so much yeah i'm willing
your honor it was love
yeah i was like you've been sentenced to
ten years that's why it's hosting as
[ __ ] she
she sacrificed her career yeah
to declare her love and i'm just like
exactly i'm just like this is a dozen
i don't care you know i don't care about
the legal ramifications she obviously
didn't get any
the point is that like it was building
up to a point like
what
yeah a part of me was just like did you
really have to announce it to the school
this is really nice because you know
that's the dramatic scene yeah
it's not like the shrek [ __ ] wedding
you don't have to be like lord farquaad
you cannot marry her because i'm going
to marry
you don't need that you know it really
doesn't add anything you could have just
been like you know what i'll see you
after school
graduate we'll [ __ ] you know that could
have been but that's boring yeah
i mean i mean it was it was dramatic
yeah it was it was it was
you need the drop you need the drop you
need the spice [ __ ] that's the
pog moment where you're like oh i can't
believe she just said that
like when he confessed to her and she
just went i know
i'm just like oh [ __ ] son she did not
just say that
what what i mean she's literally been
[ __ ] riding this boy's dick for 10
months
of course she likes her that's that's
how this [ __ ] goes but that's what i
loved about this dungeon is that it
reads like a 90s
rom-com because there's so many moments
like that
in 90s rom-coms that i've read where i'm
just like
i mean of course like i was so [ __ ]
invested in these characters
in this character's relationship more so
than like any other dojin
i've read apart from his other works
like the i mean the only reason i really
chose this was
of course gant teacher student
relationship of course i'm gonna [ __ ]
love that
i mean you know it's taboo as it is in
real life it's very attractive
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah fictional works
i don't think about the legal
ramifications when i read dojo sometimes
i do i'm sitting there and i'm like [ __ ]
dude like how many years am i getting
for this
yeah like this this isn't even his like
most highly rated works there's there's
like one which i would say is like the
children of hentai if you remember two
children it's like an anime that
focuses on different couples kind of
like and getting together and it's
wholesome as [ __ ]
and his work is basically like that but
just with the [ __ ]
included right you get the same kind of
character development you can get the
same kind of
care in the characterization as you
would in any other [ __ ] monk i would
say those
big props to you know making me actually
give a [ __ ] about the story
yeah uh despite the weird side story
again
i really want to know what the thought
process was i'd love to be here
in the board meeting i wish i was there
actually i could be like i thought it
was [ __ ] hilarious
it was but i was like halfway through
reading this chapter i was like i know
this is
gonna happen no ramifications on the
story
but it's just hilarious to read i was
just like because i knew when i
recommended this
that it was it was that scene that was
gonna get brought up and then i think
it is how can i i knew it was just going
to be the moment where it's just like
go on this your man i'm just like this
this this is not my man
literally this is not my mom get your
man i'll get you man
what i'm saying right is that two out of
three have incest gone
what's up with that what's up with that
you know whatever
he's just he likes it man they'll leave
the man's good i like it because i get
to be the judge durian executioner here
and i don't have to
i don't have to share my taste he didn't
have to show your taste i don't have any
taste oh we roasted you enough yeah
seven out of ten oh not bad i thought
the good moments were very very good
the story was pretty damn good yeah a
few moments where i thought ah
yeah all right whatever yeah and a few
moments where i'm like all right
a little too much keenness from this
lady in the start i'm like
there's no why are you into this kid is
there any any reason why is it purely
that
i don't say i don't i don't even think
she was into the kid at first really
right
because she's just joshing around yeah
she'll because i can't we'll get a woman
josh
he gonna [ __ ] around live in your
apartment bro she's like she's like
early twenties
like like doesn't get [ __ ] like the
reason that like there was like she used
they used the cat analogy so much was
because she would just basically was a
stray cat yeah
that was like the analogy i get i get it
right what i'm just like she doesn't
give a [ __ ]
good story though it was the first time
where i read a dozen and i looked at
like a character and i was like
you're not even hot you're just cute as
[ __ ] yeah honestly the reason the reason
this is my favorite of this works is
because
i [ __ ] like you had the cutest
[ __ ] [ __ ] thing the teacher's
like i love the [ __ ] teacher yeah i
think she's cute as [ __ ] yeah she's cute
[ __ ] fangirls
all right but what's most important is
this final one okay it's neither great
or my recommendation or rather it's both
of our recommendations it's both
this one we we were never going to do a
dozen episode
without talking about metamorphosis one
of the most legendary dojians out there
okay connor's never read it before okay
before we start i got something to say
i have a confession to make guys go on
oh no what are you gonna say gone
[ __ ] i have before this never read
metamorphosis really
yes wow metamorphosis has been my
full metal alchemist
[Music]
was an episode of making sure
congratulations hey i i just need
10 [ __ ] minutes to read it's not it's
not 10 500 minutes it's like a 20 20 30
minute review yeah yeah but like
it was it was the one where i'm just
like people have talked about it so much
that i had just been putting it off yeah
so it was that one hentai when i'm just
like
i will read metamorphosis when i am
ready to read metamorphosis i will say
for all i've heard about this i almost
expected it to be more [ __ ] up than it
was
did you feel that way it was pretty
[ __ ] up okay but because of the
reputation it had
i expected it to be you overhyped
yourself i thought it was going to be
even worse than it was
so did you just hype up the [ __ ] up
nurse in your head well you know i mean
i've been an anime fan for a long time
you hear about this
constantly it's referenced constantly as
being that one [ __ ] up thing
yeah you know and it's [ __ ] up for a
vanilla audience yeah
i i've watched the final season of game
of thrones i know true disappointment
and that's just kind of what it felt
like a little bit i was like this is
[ __ ] don't get me wrong it's very [ __ ]
up it is [ __ ]
well i almost expected something worse
like i almost expected like
absolutely well i think i think it's
because you've already put your
foot in the dogen and like hentai wall
yeah i mean i
i know this is like i know this is like
grade a [ __ ] off of someone who's like
never stepped foot into that right i
feel like i've seen st are [ __ ] up
and this is 80 are [ __ ] up like it's
very [ __ ] up and very uncomfortable
maybe it's just more accessible i'm not
really sure why this one has gotten a
notoriety
i think it's because this was one of i
think this was just that
one dojin that really just got around
i guess for whatever reason it is and
i'm like i should explain the promise
yeah yeah metamorphosis one of you is
very very well known
uh dojin yes about a girl
who you know she doesn't she's not the
prettiest girl out there and then she
gets a makeover
and then suddenly literally takes off
her glasses
takes off puts on a bit of makeup
becomes hot it becomes hot
and then guys you you have seen this
beginning panel
somewhere if you're in the anime
community you've seen this somewhere
it's iconic it's funny even i know what
this is yeah yeah
yeah and then i didn't i didn't know any
of the other panel which is this is the
before
and this is the after yeah yeah
completely different character
yeah and then this character is just
shocked that guys are now paying
attention to her
and that they want to [ __ ] her and so
she starts [ __ ] these guys and it
gets
really derailed really fast yeah uh yeah
it's a big yikes of a read
i mean i mean how do i explain it i mean
here's okay let me let me
let me let me just uh i i put some notes
down
seems normal so far uh not fond
of how his dad reacted to her makeup
of her dad reacted to her makeup yeah
what scene was that makeover makeover
oh yeah
so she gets a makeover and the father's
like oh okay
i was like you won't believe what
happens next i was like i was like
i do not like that i do not like that
look he gave me this does not mean good
things
and unfortunately i was correct top ten
foreshadowing moments literally
watch mojo you can take this from the
top ten short foreshadowing moments in
anime
uh yeah so you know a kind of sleazy
dude kind of uses her for sex
you know and then gives you drugs yeah i
think i think the biggest
aspect of the story which i've never
seen in any other dojinshi before
was the drug angle right yeah it was
pretty uncomfortable
yeah yeah it was pretty uncomfortable
yeah where way was like he
this so she puts on makeup she has her
makeover
and then she finds this douchebag guy
who basically gives her a drug
who and she and it's like kind of like a
mandy ripoff kind of thing yeah yeah
yeah and basically she
experiences the best sex offer or just
one of the best experiences of her life
literally the first time she
she's a virgin then and she just becomes
kind of a nymphomaniac
right where she's just and a drug addict
yeah well
a sex and a drug addict at this point
right where she's addicted to the sex
and she's addicted to the drugs and
she's
addicted to the sex and drugs and then
this it just kind of spirals
down from there it is it is it is
like it is a downward curve from like
chapter one
you know but you almost feel like when
it's when it's
when the character is like this
disconnected and like barely gives you
any
um signs of wanting to i don't know like
this
it feels so forced at times this this
this decline
of mental state where it's like all
right all right you're just doing the
[ __ ] best of depression
hits at this point or something you know
what i mean like literally you're just
trying to get
i feel like they're just making things
bad for the sake of it like there's
like a lot of the time i was like i
guess yeah
like there was a moment in it where i
was like i don't know extra doubt on
that one
where like which point which point so it
was in the school yeah where
during the story um they know that she
went to a hotel okay so
okay i suppose i should back up so she
has this boyfriend uh
you know who's kind of a scumbag gives
her drugs yeah and then she kind of
wants money so she starts [ __ ] an old
guy
who gives her money a little disturbing
and the sexy ugly bastard
literally really it's not an
uncomfortable it's it's quite
uncomfortable what am i saying it's very
uncomfortable
i don't mean to say not uncomfortable
it's very uncomfortable um
and then for some reason one of the
students finds out that she went to this
place
so naturally all of the boys together
decide
let's all get [ __ ] from her that's
that's that's what me and the boys
do at school it's like of course first
of all never going to happen
but also that was the part where i was
like i feel like this is kind of
like ah just a little extra like that
was where i was like i get it it's very
depressing but i was like
this feels really forced this part i'm
like you're making the shad for the sake
of it do you not agree with that whole
school part
i'm like this is a bit of a stretch i
mean this it's just like a trope that
i've seen in so many times and they all
start [ __ ] here and i'm like
name one school kid that minds showing
his dick to anyone let alone [ __ ]
someone in front of his friend you'd be
surprised in japan
i i don't i don't know man i i don't
know i mean
this is a culture that is grown up on
just seeing each other's dicks in the
onset
right that's like it is just probably
another day in the office
with the same [ __ ] god no no no no no
it's such a stretch that i'm like uh
i feel like they're just doing this i
mean you say it's a stress but again
it's like such a trope that you've seen
dojo
yeah yeah it happens all the time it's
not even like surprising yeah but i
guess when it's used in a way it's like
feel sorry for this girl feel like
sadness i'm like
i mean that wasn't even the part where i
felt sadness at all like it was it was
awesome
it was after that like yeah what i would
say is
this is like the requiem for a dream of
hentai
and i didn't think i would say that in
like a sentence
but it's a thing it is it is a thing
this is so
after after she sleeps with this old guy
for money after she gets blackmailed by
the other kids in a school
to have sex with them and do all this
yeah which is really horrifying it's not
portrayed very well
yeah like it's portrayed very
horrifyingly um
her dad wants a piece of the action and
this is where i'm like for [ __ ] sake
it's just like this is like literally
the the saying my day can't get any
worse
this is literally here this is lit so my
god what i even say about this thing
this is so
[ __ ] up that i'm like oh my god like
yeah what why and then she [ __ ] the dad
[ __ ] her right and it goes on and the
mum blames her and i'm like
really really like
you were married to this man for how
long and you think it's your daughter's
fault
come on come the [ __ ] on no way
i bet 99 percent of men uh uh wives
would be like
man you're out i don't care what
happened i don't care who tempted who
you're [ __ ] out
you should [ __ ] know better yeah i'm
like that's where i was like um all
right
okay okay baby maybe i'm like maybe i'll
see where this goes yeah yeah
i don't know about this move chief i
don't know could you see a world where
the mum would be like
i blame you daughter for [ __ ] that i
mean [ __ ] i don't know man
i don't know anyone who's been in that
situation
there might be who the [ __ ] knows yeah
what do you think
this is just [ __ ] weird this one was
[ __ ] weird uncomfortable
i'm like i get why it's got a reputation
but i was just like
oh no it is absolutely [ __ ] up and
it's not supposed it's it's one of those
versions where it's
not supposed to be enjoyed in the
conventional way of enjoying a donation
you know sometimes i'm a [ __ ] of
course yes
i raised this boy this is like i google
every depressing thing that could happen
in life i put it in a doujin i am how is
that a masterpiece i have
never been so engrossed in a dojin
before
like i where where like i was turning
every page i know
i know i was just like i was like
because i was thinking
where is this chatting about where is
this dozen gonna go next
i i'm 100 serious and i'm just like i
literally saw it from like
the moment she met this guy i'm like i
bet just [ __ ] up after [ __ ] up [ __ ]
is gonna
the moment she gave him drug uh he gave
her drugs i'm like i know this is going
this is just going to be it has the
greatest shown in battle of all time
dude who is going to win
one innocent girl or one spikey boy
no because like like i tried to come i
like i feel like
you came in with like a lot of
preconceived notions where you're just
like this is [ __ ] up
i'm ready for this where if if this was
a movie or a tv show or anything
this would be like just like bait here
of like this is just basic
like this is just so lazy in terms of
how how little they try to to sell this
is like a realistic
journey that i'm like you know we've had
movies about
stuff like this that are [ __ ] up that
have done this so much better
that i'm like literally requiem for a
dream just because this is in dojin
format and it's literally the only one
that's like how about we be depressing
you know it's like i don't want to give
it props for that because like i give it
props for that
i i i think it's a bit more than that
yeah but i think it's a little maybe i'm
being a little too harsh but i feel like
this has been done before in other
places
because because i i feel like men of all
metamorphosis has
like well now has to battle with it
being like the meme
dojin right because it's it's not it's
like people don't judge it on its own
merit anymore people judge it being like
haha i've seen this been memed
everywhere as like the big thing that
people
like recommend to people to like [ __ ]
them up and stuff like that and it's
like
one one thing one thing that's like i
don't like
is that people in in like the hentai
community or what i've seen people are
just like i've seen more [ __ ] up [ __ ]
than this
i've seen worse things than this and i'm
just like of course you have
i too watch euphoria i do i've seen some
of the [ __ ] that city is recommended and
[ __ ] reviewed
like i've seen the [ __ ] collection of
you know i i you know i didn't go in you
know a part of me obviously went into
singing
it's gonna be the most [ __ ] up thing
i've ever seen in my life because
everyone's recommending it but you know
it wasn't that
but then the other hand i'm like you
know it's almost trying too hard
to to make me feel sadness
for this character that i don't really
feel like they built her up
that well like honestly personally i
thought they built her up really well
it was so short and sweet and it's like
i guess
it felt very one-dimensional to me i
felt like there wasn't enough depth to
the character
and then the moment [ __ ] started going
wrong look at us there was after the
character in a different episode listen
if you want me to give a [ __ ] about this
story you sit here saying it's a
masterpiece
i'm a hit i'm gonna sit back and be like
listen i'll find i'll talk about the
characters for one goddamn minute
okay the moment [ __ ] started going wrong
for her all character development
went out the [ __ ] window that was
like nothing was added or introduced it
was like
all right it's like the it's like an
apple event it's like we've seen the
iphone
we've seen being taken advantage of let
me introduce
being taken advantage of by your father
and i was like
that's what i felt like i felt like i
was being condescended to in terms of
the [ __ ] that was coming up
okay because i i would feel like the the
thing that i
i also want to mention is that god damn
[ __ ] noel knows how to draw a good sex
scene
my [ __ ] god that's that's the thing
that's missing because like okay here's
the thing
i think [ __ ] chapter one awoke
something in me you're like
you you you remember talking about like
that new thing
yeah where he's just like wait what is
the new thing the new fetish
the new fetish is just like this girl
who
like i've i've never read a dozen where
like this sex scene is like
this intense i'm just like like the
drugs and [ __ ] yeah where
where karaoke yeah wait were they
introduced to drugs and it just like
enhanced our experience to a point where
it was just like not nothing that you
can ever experience on this earth
i don't know why i didn't enjoy that
scene that much i'm not really sure why
no that scene single-handedly awoke that
for me as well
i'm just i'm like i'm just like for me
reading that scene was just like [ __ ]
heavy breathing cats
i'm just like oh oh god [ __ ] your pc
monitor jesus christ for a second i like
understood melind for like a second
that's [ __ ] saying something right
like i i didn't i didn't know i could
feel this way
and then and then like chapter three
here and i'm just like i think like
my [ __ ] penis shriveled up and it
just inverted back into my body
right that's just like it was just just
like such a whiplash of emotions that
i'm just like
i it went from like oh that's hard to
just like what the [ __ ] am i reading
have you seen that [ __ ] like there's
a thing in the uk where they would go
and that's a tv show they go and visit
tribes and there's just one clip it's
one of my favorite clips that's right
the guy's like there's a ceremony where
they invert their penises
invert this dude's penis he immediately
faints
i just imagine i imagine that's what
happened
that's what happened to god he just it's
penis
[Music]
at his pc monitor he's like what
happened i was reading metamorphosis
there's some disempowering i mean
honestly because i feel like the
difference between me and you was just
like at a point i was into it
then i was just like okay i am not into
it anymore but i was like
i was like that's why it was so strong
for you because it was like
you were into it at one point and then
it's like it slaps you on the back of
the head it's like
stop it's the whiplash of emotion stop
it that was like
like my god like like even even during
like some of the later chapters i'm just
like
no no no no don't say no because like
his art is
[ __ ] amazing right it's it's i don't
know how he draws his sex scenes
to be this intense where i'm just like
i'm feeling emotions that i've never
felt before in my life
i was reading this praying i want to go
back to the succubus one
i really wanted to just okay okay i
gotta ask what do y'all think about
the final chapter [ __ ] up five percent
i think i think
but i think i think because i think i
almost think now hearing your guys talk
like
thoughts on it is that this manga works
amazingly ordojian works amazingly if
you get invested
really heavily in the first part and the
first sex scene yeah because then it
like
like i said it hits you in the back of
the head it's like no yeah don't be
horny
yeah it's bad but horny bad i mean it it
it like gave me such a mess of emotions
right because i'm just like i know i
shouldn't be horny right now
this is [ __ ] depressing as [ __ ] this
is [ __ ] up i didn't like the guy
at all i think that's why like i
couldn't no i didn't i didn't like the
guy at all
i was supposed to like the guy yeah but
that's to me it's like you know
i i the the whole hotness of the sex
is the duo yeah okay
someone who is that depressed shouldn't
be making those kinds of facial
expressions
the you can [ __ ] frame some of the
facial expressions
what do you mean by that like on yeah
let's talk about the art of the aha
right i'm not fond of it you know i've
been oversaturized to it yeah you've
been oversaturated
we all have right but like his like aha
girl faces
are some of the most unique [ __ ]
faces i've ever seen in all of hentai
and schindler i'm a man of the church
though that's not enough to make me
like me quiver you know i don't i don't
see that my wills are not compromised
by such such ill ill-for
i i'm sorry connor that this art piece
was so good that
it made me question it made me question
it for a second and then i was just like
no
i'm back to it this is awful this is the
prank [ __ ] name of the clip for this
[ __ ] thing
god thought [ __ ] metamorphosis was
the [ __ ] mona lisa of
dozing or some [ __ ] i i personally think
it's the mona lisa
oh like like okay okay the reason the
reason why
like i was so engrossed in it is because
it was
such like you love incest and there's
interest in it at some point god
so clearly that's why you like it it was
such a [ __ ]
mess of emotions and it was like an
emotional up and down
like it was just down from the start i
knew the moment she was like i can't
make good friends i'm like oh no that's
the only other time
i felt that depressed reading something
was awesome
it also okay i've never i've not read oh
yeah yeah i also this is the oyster also
want to put it into perspective
that i just read like three and a half
hours of porn
before this so reading this last was not
a good way to end my day
i was already quite done with reading
porn and then
you have to bear in mind there was
probably no way i was going to find
any if it was the whole that's what you
get for doing your homework the day
before
i was given the thing the day before i
was given this two days ago
so you know i think that also didn't
help because there was no way i was ever
going to find any of these things
attractive because i was pretty much
my you know i was pretty done yeah yeah
with reading paul you've read one yeah
yeah yeah yeah i've read
you show me your year's quarter of
reading i literally read like what i
think is like a normal person's like
month worth of porn in one so i was
pretty exhausted
the fact that this came up and i just
saw the right through it right away i
knew exactly what they were going to do
right from the start i was just like you
know
it's fine you know i see what you're
trying to do you're trying to make me
sad yeah
and i don't appreciate it frankly it's
not i want a happy ending
he's not done well i you know the whole
like at the moment that her dad looked
at her i'm like i see what you're doing
here buddy
your next line is i i i actually we keep
talking about the dad but i think that
dad
is the worst part of the dojin because
it was just like
for me reading the dad episode was just
like let's just start just let's see
i would rather eat my own toenails yeah
and read them again
but like like what like what like it was
after the dad donation
that the dad chapter part when i'm just
like yo this is
this is really engrossing as a story
right
i knew it was going there the moment he
gave her a drug i'm like
he's literally gonna sell her later on
and use drugs for yeah
so obviously it was going there and so
when it went there i was like i was not
even surprised
the dad thing caught me off guard i had
a feeling it might happen and then when
it did happen i'm like for [ __ ]
sake yeah god damn it
god damn it because cause like to me it
was just like
it was just it was just the feeling of
just being like this is the most
depraved [ __ ]
i shouldn't feel horny at all this
situation
are people jacking off to this i don't
think so i don't know probably something
i mean because the thing is the thing is
it was it was
it was that emotion juxtaposed between
how
amazing the sex scenes were cause like
out of context
extra doubt on this no out of context
out of context no i don't think the sex
the art the art was [ __ ] amazing was
[ __ ] ugly bastards so how much was to
get behind that [ __ ]
i mean it wasn't all ugly it wasn't all
it was
okay so it was we had two very big
scenes
with older men yeah and it was very
gross because
there were there were six chapters and
two maybe three of them were ugly bosses
and
which frankly three one is too many
i mean the fact that i read this [ __ ]
and i thought it's bad enough she's
[ __ ] some random dude for money
who is literally the ugliest man on
earth yeah and then next it's like
it's like [ __ ] smash bros introducing
a new fighter
a [ __ ] dad into this [ __ ] up story
which is already pressing as [ __ ]
because
everyone in the [ __ ] school has had a
go at her yeah it's just like that
that [ __ ] alone i was like you know what
like i i i sh
yeah sure japanese kids are [ __ ] up
but like this is too much
and this would never happen no way in
any school would this ever happen
well it's interesting because like i
interviewed shinderwell
like a couple of years ago yeah and we
talked about this i was like because i
wanted to know i was like
what you know inspired metamorphosis um
and he said that
he because he was born and raised in new
york yeah so he was like
i heard and saw so many stories
that were similar to this right and he
was like i wanted to bring light to it
because
otherwise no one [ __ ] talks about it
i bet this [ __ ]
has happened like separately
yeah like all of these individual things
no no absolutely definitely yeah yeah
but this isn't based off of really
i know i know but the fact that like you
string these all together to a point
where i'm just like i suspend my
disbelief and i'm like yeah
no it's not supposed to be realistic but
it's supposed to be it's it's basically
i think it in my opinion it was shindo
all being like look this [ __ ] happens
but like i think about movies that [ __ ]
me up and i think that could be me i
could make that mistake
i could be in that situation in this one
i was like this is
well yeah because you're not a chick but
even then like i feel like it was it was
trying too hard
well then i i think the most fantastical
element was it of it
was how much he enjoyed the sex right
because because
because that was that was i feel that
was the big difference
between that was also an uncomfortable
part i'm like is this
is this good is it what she wants i
don't know that's the one that's
that's the most interesting that to me
is what like drew me in
was like was was like the fact that she
enjoyed the sex so much which i know
it's like
is that resource music no no no that's
that's the point right where it's just
like
it's such a like a mess of emotions that
it's just like you don't you have no
grounding
it questions your morality the entire
time there's like no grounding
on this kind of situation because
personally i don't know anyone who's
[ __ ] their dads
and i kind of i kind of want to keep it
that way you know
like that's that's just me i don't know
if that's a hot take but like i just i
just
i hope that i hope that that never
happens to any [ __ ] body
yeah but i mean yeah that's the point it
is it's [ __ ] it's
it's it's fiction right yeah but like
the the thing that drew me in was that
it was just these [ __ ] up situations
juxtaposed between
sex scenes that she obviously really
enjoyed at the time
right and i'm just like yo this is like
really
weird this is like a weird car crash of
different [ __ ] things i shouldn't be
feeling right now but i'm just like
i don't know how to like i'm still like
processing it now right because it's
like the only time
the reason i call it the reason i call
this the masterpiece is that
it's the only time i felt this emotion
that i'm trying to describe right now
right
normally normally you get depressed
normally you get horny you don't talk
about depression
depression boner do you like like that
that just doesn't happen
right but metamorphosis is just these
two [ __ ] things that shouldn't
coexist together
together i'm just like what what yeah
it's it's and that's why i think it's
brilliant as well it's because
he took such a [ __ ] risk with this
where he was like
this could have easily just been like a
weird thing that no one would have
picked up and then just like brushed
under
all of the oh okay that's [ __ ] weird
let's not talk about that pile of dogens
that are out there
but there was just again he just
presented it in a way
where it was just like you came for the
horny
but you're gonna stay for the depression
whether you like it or not yeah
and like i don't know any other dojin
that's managed to do that and
managed to make me stay the entire time
until the end
have you ever seen uh the shadow buff
movie nymphomaniac
no i haven't that's like the three hour
long one right it's like there's two
parts to it yeah
yeah yeah i felt like that was a really
uncomfortable depiction of a woman who's
addicted to sex
right i felt like that was really
somewhat well done
i thought that's an interesting movie
it's a very hard watch yeah really
it's very long yeah yeah it's very
uncomfortable because it's that
it's that that [ __ ] like uh really
avant-garde director
yeah it is and it's one of those things
where it's like it really reminds you
like you think you're cool with sex
until you see it in really uncomfortable
ways and you're like yeah
yeah that's the last one true movie i i
kind of have weird
thoughts about because it really makes
you be like oh you're comfortable with
sex
bet yeah like and i feel like
you know having experienced that kind of
weird [ __ ] i feel like going into this
i'm like yeah i can kind of buy why
she's into it but also
i feel like it's been done better in
different places almost
not saying that movie did it better
essentially but i feel like i've seen
it down in a way where i'm like i think
this is done slightly more realistic to
the point where i'm like i believe it i
believe it
yeah right but it's hard to like i get
it how like you know movies like
nephromaniac
probably did this whole thing better
yeah but at the same time neither maniac
has
the upside of being more realistic by
using real actors that's true i mean we
shouldn't
like the the biggest thing because it's
hard to for me personally
to who's never read doujins to see this
and be like damn that's [ __ ] that's
art man that's
yeah i mean like
i mean we we literally just chucked you
in the deep end and just like
fit like try to see yeah i mean you know
it's like i i'm not used to this genre
yeah you know i mean i don't think
anyone is there's all these kind of
tropes in here
and then there's this girl happens just
to believe is this kind of well done
character and i'm like yeah i don't
believe it man personally at least
i mean possibly at least you can now say
you read men
i've read it i'm not proud of that fact
i want to undo the reading that i've
done so what would you give it out of 10
in terms of what in terms of just like
like how you felt about it
four four it's an interesting read and
what were you
ten hell yeah oh hell yeah
what does sydney think of it um i don't
know what sydney thinks about you should
ask
and frankly i'm afraid to ask because i
should be like it's the hardest [ __ ]
i i have heard too many things that have
worried me in my past the past few
months of my relationship
that i'm kind of afraid to ask her
opinion of like any hentai right now
so i guess i'll leave it at that then
huh
jesus christ it was uh i appreciate you
guys introducing me to the
wonderful world of um
so has this experience changed your
perspective
at all or i mean i still have my
preferred methods
yeah right but i got my systems in place
but would you
ever in your late afternoon i mean go
back to like try another dojo like
if i was recommending uh dergen that was
uh highly praised i i would go and read
it i mean it's not it's not too
difficult
yeah but hopefully it's not too long
yeah i i i would say the biggest
appeal about reading doujian's or highly
rated doujinshi is like you
i mean you've talked about finding that
one hentai that's [ __ ] like
like the diamonds in this like [ __ ]
right
there's so much choice with dojinshi
because there's like obviously
so much right infinite amount of time
there's
there's way more choice than there is
for hentai and you can find
way more doujins that are like
specifically
garnished to your choice i just really
enjoy voice acting
so much and especially in that manner i
really enjoy what it adds to it
i feel like it helps sell my
believability to me
the best the best tag you can possibly
get is plot
plot is the best spice isn't it tragic
that it has to be a tag though
they're like it's it's not a given that
everything else i don't want plot in my
life
somebody's like no no i don't want the
plumber turning up today
i i don't want the pizza man delivering
it but you know the fact that we're
talking about the plumber and the pizza
man just shows
how [ __ ] devoid of plot every [ __ ]
porno is that we've gotten this kind of
mentality where
you're like oh plot kind of hot you know
knowing the context of why people are
[ __ ]
that's kind of hot you know is that it's
is that such a hard to me not being a
[ __ ] monkey and just
scratching my nuts to people [ __ ] you
know great fantastic
you know wow my god well i'm just glad
connor that we managed to finally do
this episode because we've we've been
talking about doing this episode for
quite a while now we were like
yeah two out of three loved ocean monkey
man over here
doesn't want to read i feel at this
point we should just make it like a a
yeah this is like about six months after
the hentai episode we'll do another
hentai oh my god it's already been six
months
yeah i know right sorry i just talked to
[ __ ] much
i can't honestly this has been such a
[ __ ] episode it's such a [ __ ] fun
episode
a [ __ ] episode it has been a [ __ ]
this has been a [ __ ] episode
you know the succubus one i'm praying
gets it oh yeah yeah so
yeah so out of the seven what's your
favorite can i rank them in order sure
all right
metamorphosis is the worst one least
favorite to most favorite it's a member
of officers okay so
metamorphosis is by far the worst one
very close
last second last place the [ __ ] orimo
one
[ __ ] that one [ __ ] that
so that's what gone in the bottom so far
yeah um
i will say that probably after that
is ah
it's gotta be the the first one
yeah yeah that one i wasn't too fond of
yeah and then
third i guess is
this difficult
take out the shoe okay okay shoulder the
shoulder one yeah
i'll give it to the sensei one okay okay
fifth i'll give it to peace peace yeah
and first place it was succubus wow
that's pretty balanced then that's
pretty balanced yeah actually yeah
that's not bad well you recommend the
succubus one right yeah yeah so yeah i'd
say
it's my one yeah i'd say you both gave
me
you know i was shocked i was expecting
worse from you i was expecting
i was expecting lolli orc gangbangs from
jerry
and from i was expecting the whole
family [ __ ] each other thankfully i
mean
i mean we could have recommended that
pretty [ __ ] close with the original
one right
and the whole family came up for fun
with that one [ __ ] me and uh you haven't
finished piece of harmony so i'm just
gonna leave it there
the thing is we can only recommend three
so like when you're choosing three
dojinshi that's like a [ __ ] hard
choice
it's like it's it's like it's like
choosing between your children
i was just like i wanted to recommend
like one of the top tier milf ones but
i'm just like
there's not this like there's not enough
space you can recommend me like one good
one and two ones that you know i [ __ ]
hate but yeah
obviously you know what you can do give
us a list of tags and we'll find you
something milf milf milf milk
stepmom stepmom stepmom stepmom mother
knows breast
i don't know you know it's it's likely i
don't like incest
but i'd like to tell you boys i'm gonna
go here i'm gonna go home today
a changed man reading dojins but i'm not
i'm definitely not next one is the
arrogant episode so we gotta we gotta
recommend some arrogance no because
they're like 10 hours long
they're like 100 hours long what i want
to do for the next episode is like the
uh adult manwa that's uh
that's an uh that's the genre i've been
getting into honestly
i think adult manwa story wise is even
better than some dojinshi yeah we
recommend conor some adult
i i feel like connor would very much be
into
me i've never been corrupted until today
hey if you also like to be corrupted or
watch this uh episode
uncensored then uh make sure to support
us on patreon patreon.com look at all
these lovely dj look at all these lovely
degenerates are
already there probably watching this
uncensored already
just five beautiful dollars you can see
all of the glorious
mentions yeah you can see all the panels
i don't know how to talk about the
beautiful beautiful scenes the beautiful
scenes
you can see the beautiful art yeah but
hey if you
enjoy it then yeah make sure to support
us on patreon also follow us on twitter
send us your memes on the subreddit and
if you hate our faces or i mean this is
going to be a weird episode to listen to
on spotify but you can listen to us on
spotify as well so go check that out
thank you so much for joining us
see you later guys bye bye bye
[Music]
you